Hey there. Thank you for being here. A
warm welcome to you, especially if this
is your first time with us, Adventist or
otherwise.
Tonight we are getting into our final
installment in a response to SDA
scholars, Christopher Cernaki and Jud
Lake, who is a professor at Southern
Adventist University, a former professor
of mine at that. Um, they issued a
response to this platform uh some weeks
ago. Now, if you missed the previous
parts, I highly recommend listening to
those as some of what I'm going to be
saying tonight, just like last week,
will piggy back off of that. In the
interest of time, I will not be
rehashing all of that as we have quite a
bit to listen to tonight. This will be
uh well, this was the longest portion of
their response and this will more than
likely be the longest portion of mine as
well.
If you recall
in part one, we looked at how
foundational the great controversy
worldview is to the DNA of Seventh Day
Adventism. That it is not just a
fundamental belief, but it is uh what
the SDA church filters all of their
thought and theology through which is an
extra biblical paradigm and why um they
or or rather how they use basic
Christian terminology such as grace,
gospel, atonement. Um, but that doesn't
really tell us anything about Adventism
because it's not the words that are in
question, but what they mean by those
words.
It was important that they started
there. I'm glad that they did because it
was important that we started there as
well because that needs to be understood
in light of the rest of the parts like
we saw in part two where we looked at
how the gospel of Adventism is a false
gospel. Departs from what the scriptures
put forth. This is of course again due
to the influence of the great
controversy theme. And then tonight in
part three, we are going to examine the
final fundamental belief that they chose
which is number 18, Ellen White and the
gift of prophecy. In line with what
we've done previously, I will steal
manand the SDA position utilizing
primary source documentation clearly
reiterating and laying out the
objections that I've publicly made not
just on this platform but many years
prior to this platform even being
around. Then we will listen to their
response and see if it hits the mark.
But first, before getting into it,
if you like what we're doing here, you
can support us by becoming a channel
member. For the price of about a cup of
coffee a month, you can not only help us
fulfill our mission, but you will gain
access to our growing library of
membersonly content. You can come hang
out at our membersonly live streams
where we work through any questions that
you might have and do some more hands-on
type discussion. If this is something of
interest, click that little join button
down below this video. You can use the
link as well in the description box or
if you don't see either of those, you
can visit our channel homepage like you
see on screen where you will find the
same one. The newest installment of this
will go up tomorrow where we look at uh
Dr. O from down at Stateline SDA church
in Alabama who uh this past week said
that I am deceived by Satan and had a
meltdown over a discussion that I had
with Douglas Wilson uh some months back
regarding the Sunday law. I finally made
an appearance at Dr. O's Sunday law
watch parties on Sundays down at uh his
church. But in the process, he evidenced
he had no clue what he was even watching
and responding to, which is part for the
course for him. But it made for quite a
fun and entertaining response from our
end and is a perfect example of how The
Great Controversy and Great Controversy
theology in particular really is a mind
virus that inhibits critical thinking.
Your support really does make a huge
difference and this work would not be
possible without you. So big shout out
and a big thank you to all of our
channel members. All right, so you will
recall if you saw in part one that I
reached out to Dr. Lake in October of
2023 to see if he would entertain
recording a discussion together
regarding tonight's particular topic,
Ellen White and her writings, as well as
some of the content in his book. Ellen
White under fire. As a former student of
his and someone that has discussed the
subject with him before, I thought it
could be beneficial to have a public
discussion with him to let a qualified
representative present the SDA position.
I just wanted to ask questions, let him
answer, ask another question, let him
answer, etc. I made that very clear that
he would receive all the footage as
well, completely raw and unedited. To no
shock, he declined the invitation,
stating that he had no interest in
debate, but that he had already said all
that he needed on the subject in his
book, some of which we will be looking
at tonight. But clearly this was not the
case because instead of having that
discussion with me face to face, he
resorted to responding to the platform
uh from another platform that he was
invited onto, which further evidences
that he very clearly did not say all
that he wanted to on the subject,
especially considering uh this is the
largest section of his response. For
those that may not know, this is Dr.
Lake's particular area of expertise. So
it makes sense as to why he spent the
most time on this section. But let's
start at the top of my objections, shall
we?
Beginning with the general conference's
statement of confidence in the writings
of LG White. In part they write
quote
on the centennial of her death we
rejoice that her writings Ellen Whites
have made available uh have been made
available around the globe in many
languages and in a variety of printed
and electronic formats.
We reaffirm our conviction that her
writings are divinely inspired, truly
Christc centered and Bible- based.
Rather than replacing the Bible, they
uplift the normative character of
scripture and correct inaccurate
interpretations of it derived from
tradition, human reason, personal
experience, and modern culture.
Close quote.
So notice it says her writings. It does
not say her conflict of the ages series
or any sort of clarifier.
Adventists love to try to use that
defense. If you cite something outside
the conflict of the ages series or
Christ object lessons, then you don't
actually understand how Ellen White's
writings are utilized within the SDA
church. You'll recall in part one Dr.
Lakes quoting from manuscript releases
across the whole gamut. Dr. O, we
mentioned him earlier. He he's just
citing all across the gamut. But if
you're if you're critical and and you're
thinking critically, um, oh well, you
you you just you don't understand you
you you don't understand how Ellen
White's writings work. Yeah. Okay. Yeah,
nice try. No, the GC's statement states
that they uphold the conviction that
Elamite's writings are divinely inspired
and that they correct inaccurate
interpretations of scripture by
uplifting the normative character of it.
Meaning, without her writings, you can't
truly understand what the Bible is
teaching. You need them to truly
navigate through the Bible without
getting shipwrecked. which is precisely
the analogy that Uriah Smith used in the
January 13, 1863 issue of the SDA church
paper, The Review and Herald. Dr. Lake
even notes this quote in his book. This
analogy is also found as well in the
Adventist belief fundamental beliefs
book. Notice
quote
one illustration may help to set this
matter in a still clearer light. Suppose
we are about to start upon a voyage. The
owner of the vessel gives us a book of
directions telling us that it contains
instructions sufficient for our whole
journey and that if we will heed them,
we shall reach in safety our port of
destination.
Setting sail, we open our book to learn
its contents. We find that its author
lays down general principles
to govern us in our voyage and instructs
us as far as practicable
touching the various contingencies that
may arise till the end. But he also
tells us that latter part of our journey
will be especially peril
that the features of the coast are ever
changing by reason of quicksands and
tempest.
But for this part of the journey, says
he, I have provided you a pilot who will
meet you and give you such directions as
the surrounding circumstances and
dangers may require. and to him you must
give heed.
With these directions we roach the
perilous time specified and the pilot
according to promise appears.
But some of the crew as he offers his
services rise up against him. We have
the original book of directions, say
they, and that is enough for us. We
stand upon that and that alone. We want
nothing of you.
Who now heed that original book of
directions?
Those that reject the pilot or those who
receive him as that book instructs them.
Judge ye
close quote.
So in the review and herald article,
Smith argues Protestants have always
upheld solos scriptor of which he
erroneously defines the same way Ellen
White did Bible onlyism. Not that
scripture alone is the only infallible
rule of faith and practice, which is
what solos scripture actually is. Not
Bible only.
The book like Smith appeals to one of
their favorite catch uh catchall proof
texts, Revelation 12:17, to claim that
prophecy foretold of a great crisis at
the end where Satan would be engaging in
his final attack to destroy Adventists.
So that proves that Ellen White's
necessary to pilot the ship and tell us
how to properly understand the Bible.
But nevertheless, the SDA church
utilizes Smith's analogy in the
exposition of their own beliefs
regarding Ellen White. God has given a
book of directions, the Bible, which is
sufficient for the whole journey.
Following it will lead to safety uh uh
to safely arriving at the port. One then
opens the Bible to learn of its contents
where general principles are laid down
governing the voyage.
But the book also contains warnings that
times of peril will come along the
journey. And for part of that journey,
God has provided a pilot that will give
directions as to the surrounding
circumstances of that peril, allowing
them to navigate through it.
They then point to people like
Protestants and others saying, "We're
the crew that's saying we don't need
Ellen White. The Bible's enough." But
the book supposedly supports Ellen White
as the divinely inspired messenger to
give the proper understanding of the
Bible. So who's really following the
Bible? They rhetorically ask. The ones
who say we only need scripture or the
ones who say we need scripture, but
scripture teaches us also that we're
supposed to yield to God's end times
messenger who is the pilot of the
journey.
This analogy breaks down due to circular
reasoning. And it highlights another
problem I've talked about, and that's
the SDA catch22 of needing Ellen White
to truly understand the Bible. Yet,
Smith and the SDA church tell us the
Bible supports the idea of there needing
to be an end times pilot that God sends
to pilot the ship.
But this is perfectly in line with
everything I've said from this platform
and why I've constantly said they do not
affirm soloscripura. They need to stop
confusing people and trying to claim
that they do.
They administ claim I'm misrepresenting
all they want to soo their conscience.
But that's the facts. If you need Ellen
White to understand the Bible and you're
going to the Bible to say, "Well, the
Bible tells us there's going to be an
end times prophet." Well, you how do you
know you're properly understanding the
Bible? Then you have to have her to
properly understand the Bible. This is
the problem with infallible
interpreters. Period. they become the
ultimate authority because you can't say
the Bible's the ultimate authority if
you have to have the infallible
interpreter to even understand the the
infallible Bible. But now notice from
the June 3rd, 1971 review and Herald, we
have looked at this I don't know how
many times.
Quote,
Protestants have always claimed that the
Bible is its own interpreter. Yes, the
perspectuity of scripture as well.
Perhaps it is better to say the spirit
of prophecy. We use the term here as
synonymously
with the gift of prophecy or testimony
of Jesus is its own interpreter. The
Bible is an infallible guide but it
needs to be infallibly interpreted to
avoid confusion and division. Close
quote. Ah this is what the statement of
confidence from the GC says. This is
what Uriah Smith says in the same paper.
And this is what they are saying against
almost a hundred years after Uriah
Smith's statement here in the paper
over and over and over again. They are
stating that Ellen White's writings are
the infallible interpreter of scripture.
And without them, you end up in
confusion and division despite the fact
uh that that's the SDA church to a tea.
It's just full of confusion and
division. But this means that without
Ellen White, we can't understand the
Bible. So, claiming that the Bible
teaches that God would send an end times
pilot to help infallibly navigate the
trip begs the question
because again, we can't even understand
the Bible without her writing
supposedly. So, how can you know that
scripture is telling you this without
assuming it to be the case?
That's why I'm constantly on record
saying Ellen White's writings,
practically speaking, I know they're not
going to say this. They're going to say,
"No, no, no. She's not above the Bible.
No, no, no." Yeah, I know they say that
they say a lot of things. There's a lot
of double speak in Adventism,
but practically speaking, Ellen White's
writings are over the Bible.
If you can't understand it without an
infallible interpreter, then the
infallible interpreter becomes the
premier standard. Now, notice another
statement that we've looked at numerous
times
from former GC President GI Butler in
the August 14, 1883 Review and Herald
supplement, quote,
"Our position on the testimonies, Ellen
White's writings, is like the keystone
to the arch.
Take that out and there's no logical
stopping place till all the special
truths of the message are gone.
Our enemies and the master they serve
realize this, but some of our people are
so blind that they do not. Close quote.
So, it isn't just that Ellen White's
writings are the infallible interpreter
of scripture. They're the lifeblood of
Adventism.
It depends on her writings. All the
special truths, not some, all
like that. They're God's last day
remnant with a special life or death
message that only they have to take to
the rest of the rest of the world. That
all collapses if Ellen White is removed.
And Butler wasn't like a lot of these
modern SDAs who try and say otherwise
because he says the enemies of the SDA
movement know this to be the case. But
unfortunately, many Adventists are so
blind and can't see it. So take note of
that. Adventist
connected with this.
We also see something else interesting
from fundamental belief number 18
itself.
Notice what it says.
The scriptures testify that one of the
gifts of the Holy Spirit is prophecy.
This gift is an identifying mark of the
remnant church and we believe it was
manifested in the ministry of Ellen G.
White.
Her writings speak with prophetic
authority and provide comfort, guidance,
instruction, and correction to the
church. They also make clear that the
Bible is the standard by which all
teaching and experience must be tested.
Yeah, we can't test her writings up
against the Bible because they've
already told us we need her writings to
properly interpret the Bible.
But despite that,
and that they also make clear that her
writings speak with prophetic authority,
they claim that she displayed the
identifying mark of the remnant church,
further evidencing that if Ellen goes,
the whole thing goes.
You can't be like, "Oh, I'm an
Adventist, but I reject Ellen White."
Okay, well then you reject being the
remnant.
Now, it's just a domino effect. But
notice the phrase, a source of prophetic
authority. What's a source, folks?
What is a source?
It's where something begins or starts.
It's not a channel or a stream. A
source.
And even in the proof text that they
give for this fundamental belief, they
include 2 Timothy 3:16-1 17 and mimic
the language, but they apply it to her
writings.
Her writings supposedly provide comfort,
guidance, instruction, and correction to
the church, meaning the SDA church.
But that's what Paul says about
scripture in 2 Timothy 3:16.
And then they include that in the proof
text for this particular fundamental
belief. So don't let Adventists try and
tell you the organization does not view
her writings as equal with scripture.
Give me a break. Also notice the last
sentence. Her writings make clear that
the Bible is the standard. Right? But
they already told us you can't
understand the Bible without her. Which
is why this is actually a statement that
upholds Ellen's authority, not
scripture.
Oh, it's Ellen's writings that let us
know that the the Bible is the standard.
On top of that, you'll have some
Adventists that love to assert we I
mean, we hear this every week from some
person. Ellen White never claimed to be
a prophet.
These folks unfortunately have drank the
Kool-Aid and clearly haven't looked at
the quote that they are referencing,
which we will do momentarily. But even
if that were the case, then why does the
fundamental belief plainly state that
her writings speak with prophetic
authority?
For those that have never seen this
quote,
notice what she actually says.
Quote,
"During the discourse, I said that I did
not claim to be a prophetus. Some were
surprised at this statement, and as much
is being said in regard to it, I will
make an explanation."
Others have called me a prophetus, but
I've never assumed that title.
I've not felt that it was my duty thus
to designate myself. Those who boldly
assume that they are prophets in this
our day are often a reproach to the
cause of Christ.
My work includes much more than this
name signifies.
I regard myself as a messenger entrusted
by the Lord with messages for his
people.
When this work was first given me, I
begged the Lord to lay the burden on
someone else. The work was so large and
broad and deep that I feared I could not
do it.
I've been weak and feeble physically
much of my life, but by his Holy Spirit,
the Lord has given me the ability to
perform the work entrusted to me. God
has made plain to me the various ways in
which he would use me to carry forward a
special work. Visions have been given me
with the promise, if you deliver the
message faithfully and endure until the
end, you shall eat of the fruit of the
tree of life and drink of the water of
the river of life. Lowe's quote.
So she gives her own explanation. She
didn't call herself a prophet because
that name wasn't enough. Not because she
was downplaying herself.
She said the work that she was doing
encompassed far more than that title
signified.
The exact opposite of what many SDAs
claim when they when they try to appeal
to this. The same people who will claim
I'm taking her out of context do the
exact thing they're accusing me of.
But God has supposedly made plain to her
in various ways how she was to carry
forward the special work and she was
given promises and vision that if she
faithfully delivered these messages as
God's messenger and endured until the
end, she would essentially be saved.
So if you hear an Adventist tell you
this, Ellen White never claimed to be a
prophet. understand she was not
downplaying herself, which is exactly
why now we're going to look at some more
statements she made regarding her own
writings. First up,
Testimonies for the Church, Volume 5,
page 661.
Quote, "In ancient times, God spoke to
men by the mouth of the prophets and
apostles. In these days, he speaks to
them by the testimonies of his spirit.
There was never a time when God
instructed his people more earnestly
than he instructs them now concerning
his will and the course that he would
have them pursue. Close quote.
So she twists Hebrews 1 which says, "In
ancient times, God spoke through the
apostles and prophets, but in these days
he has spoken to us through his son, the
Lord Jesus." and she replaces the sun
with her writings, the testimonies.
Maybe you did, maybe you didn't, but
back in fundamental belief uh in the in
the fundamental belief, if you look at
the footnotes, Hebrews 1 1-3 was also
listed as a support for Ellen White.
This is because that's what the SDA
church teaches regarding her writings.
Again, don't give us this nonsense that
no, no, no, she's not on par with the
Bible.
Yeah.
This is what they try to argue.
The spirit of prophecy is the testimony
of Jesus which is found in the writings
of Ellen White. They claim that
Revelation says the spirit of prophecy
is the testimony of Jesus and the
testimony of Jesus is wherever Jesus is
speaking.
They are supposedly the ones keeping the
commandments of God that Satan is making
war against. Thus, because Ellen White
manifested the gift of prophecy, Jesus
is speaking in her writings.
Now, we're going to demonstrate the
invalidity of this in a moment, but
notice that Ellen White said that God
has never instructed people more than he
instructs them now by way of her
writings.
Not the apostles, not even Jesus
himself.
Ellen White was used by God more than
any other human being to ever grace the
earth to instruct people more than he
ever has at any time.
But again, same book, Testimonies for
the Church, Volume Five, quote, "I know
your danger. If you lose confidence in
the testimonies, you will drift away
from Bible truth.
I've been fearful that many would take a
questioning, doubting position, and in
my distress for your souls, I would warn
you. How many will heed the warning?
As you now hold the testimonies, should
one be given crossing your track,
correcting your errors? Would you feel
it perfect liberty to accept or reject
any part or the whole?
That which you will be least inclined to
receive is the very part most needed.
God and Satan never work in
co-artnership.
The testimonies either bear the signate
of God or that of Satan.
Close quote.
So in giving instruction to the SDA
church, that's what the testimonies are.
They're supposedly directly from God.
She states that if one loses confidence
in her testimonies, you'll drift away
from the Bible.
And then she rhetorically asks, "If one
crosses the path of an Adventist, will
they feel that liberty to accept or
reject it?
And that which they are least inclined
to receive is the most important part."
But then she very plainly tells us that
the testimonies either bear the signate
mark of Satan or God. Can't be both.
And this is the consistent theme from
her. She said the same thing in a letter
to JN Andrews and others.
writes a similar thing in Last Day
events, which is a compilation book.
Notice, quote, it's Satan's plan to
weaken the faith of God's people in the
testimonies.
Next follows skepticism in regard to the
vital points of our faith, the pillars
of our position. Oh, right. Like GI
Butler said, then doubt as to the holy
scriptures and then the downward march
to predition.
When the testimonies which were once
believed are doubted and given up, Satan
knows the deceived or Satan knows the
deceived ones will not stop at this and
he redoubles his efforts till he
launches them into open rebellion which
becomes incurable and ends in
destruction.
Close quote.
Exactly what GI Butler was saying in his
quote. Doubting Ellen White and her
testimonies, her writings will lead a
person to being skeptical of Adventism
entirely, leading to a rejection of the
pillars of their movement, which will
eventually lead to doubting the Bible
outright, and one will eventually end up
in pdition.
This is fear-based cult-like behavior to
keep people locked in and fearful of
even questioning, using their critical
thinking.
It's supposedly the work of Satan for
you to critically question her writings.
This is why it's hard to take this this
notion seriously that that the no no,
the Bible's the final standard, the end-
all beall,
or like the fundamental belief says that
her writings make clear that the Bible
is the standard by which all teaching
and experience must be tested.
Yet, if you do this and end up
disagreeing with her or pointing out
errors, well, you'll be ousted or
expected to tow the party line, you
know, like Dez Ford. Dez Ford did
exactly this and showed how the book of
Hebrews contextually absolutely
decimates Adventist theology. Yet, the
response was that, well, we didn't see
light in his understanding.
Remember that's what William Johnson
said on the John Ankerberg show when he
was asked about this. Well, why are the
guys that are upholding what was stated
in Questions on doctrine, why are they
being fired? What about people like Dez
Ford? John Akerberg asks. William
Johnson said, 'Well, at Glacier View, we
didn't see light in his interpretation.
Aka, it didn't jive with Ellen White
from selected messages book three.
Quote, "The Holy Ghost is the author of
the scriptures and of the spirit of
prophecy."
These are not to be twisted and turned
to mean what man want them to mean, to
carry out man's ideas and sentiments, to
carry forward man's schemes at all
hazards. Close quote.
For those that do not know, spirit of
prophecy is also a euphemism within
Adventism to refer to the body of Ellen
White's writings as a whole. Here she
plainly says, "The Holy Spirit authored
them no differently than the Bible. The
Holy Spirit is the author of both. same
book.
Quote, "I have the most precious matter
to reproduce and place before the people
in testimony form.
While I'm able to do this work, the
people must have things to revive past
history,
that they may see that there is one
straight chain of truth without one
heretical sentence in that which I have
written.
This I am instructed
is to be a living letter to all in
regard to my faith.
Close quote. One straight chain of truth
in her writings without one heretical
sentence. Earlier on in the same book,
the Bible must be your counselor. study
it and the testimonies God has given for
they never contradict his word.
Close quote. So not one heretical
sentence,
what she writes never contradicts God's
word, not just the testimonies for the
church, but her corpus of writings. They
either bear the signate mark of Satan or
God. And elsewhere she writes repeatedly
that her writings bear the test of
investigation.
Now, this was only a small sampling of
claims that she's made regarding her own
writings. All things that I've pointed
out before and have taken umbrage with,
which is why we're now going to do the
final step, which is demonstrate from
scripture that no, she doesn't even come
close to passing the biblical test of a
prophet. Okay? We will only look at a
handful that I've mentioned from this
platform, but there are far more than
this, and you can see all of these on
our website.
But first, notice what she wrote to SDA
pioneer JN Lowro. This was in 1874.
Okay, clear my throat here.
She writes, "I hereby testify in the
fear of God that the charges of Miles
Grant, of Mrs. Berdick, and others
published in the crisis are not true.
The statements in reference to my course
in 44, talking about 1844, are false.
With my brethren and sisters after the
time passed in 44, I did believe no more
sinners would be converted.
But I never had a vision that no more
sinners would be converted. and am clear
and free to state. No one has ever heard
me say or has read from my pen
statements which will justify them in
the charges they have made against me
upon this point.
Close quote.
So she states
in 1874 that after the great
disappointment back in 1844,
she did believe that no more sinners
would be converted, but never had a
vision of such.
She's clear and free to state that no
one had ever heard her say or read from
her pen statements that would justify
this charge, which is the charge that
was being brought against her by Lucinda
Berdick and Miles Grant.
Notice what Mrs. Berdick's charge was.
This is from her statement on the
visions of Ellen G. Harmon because she
wasn't Ellen White yet, which is a
letter. Notice quote
the influence of the avenous movement
talking about the Millerites there of
1843 and 1844 reached me but I did not
understand their arguments nor was I in
any way identified with them until the
year 1845.
I first heard of Miss LG Harmon
afterwards Mrs. Ellen G. White. In the
early winter, January or February of
1845,
when my uncle Josiah Little came to my
house and reported that he had seen one
Ellen Harmon in the act of having
visions, which she claimed were given
her of God.
E said that she declares that God
revealed to her that the door of mercy
was closed forever and that there was
henceforth no salvation for sinners.
In the afternoon of the same Sunday in
October, White preached at the house of
Andrew Bod uh uh Andrew Boge about a
half mile from my uncle's residence.
That's talking about James White. And
the whole burden of his sermon was that
the door of mercy had been closed the
10th day of the seven month in the year
of 1844.
That there was henceforth no salvation
for sinners, and that God was revealing
himself to his people through visions.
close quote.
This was her charge and it was written
in 1908
which demonstrates that she maintained
this charge not just early on but for
decades.
She even claimed that James White was
preaching this message as well. It
wasn't just Ellen but Ellen claimed to
have a vision regarding it
and this was the charge that Ellen was
responding to. Miss Berdick.
But notice what else Ellen had to say in
the same chapter of Selected Messages.
Quote,
"I never have stated or written that the
world was doomed or damned.
I never have under any circumstances
used this language to anyone, however
sinful.
I have ever had messages of reproof for
those who used these harsh expressions.
Close quote.
Ah,
so she claims that not only she never
had a vision regarding the salvation of
sinners being closed, but also that she
never stated or wrote that the world was
doomed. Under no circumstances did she
ever use that language regarding anyone,
no matter how sinful they were. In fact,
she claimed to have messages of strong
reproof for people who did use such
harsh expressions.
She made a similar statement in 1883,
which is in the same book, Selected
Messages book one on page 63.
But now notice a letter from Ellen
published in the August 1st, 1849 issue
of Present Truth magazine, 28 years
before her statement in 1874.
It is a little bit long. Sorry, it is a
little bit long, but we need to read
most of it to see what is being said.
Notice
present truth, August 1st, 1849.
Dear brethren and sisters,
the Lord has shown me that it is my duty
to relate to you what he has revealed to
me relating to the present truth or
present tried scattered and tempted
state and our duty in view of the coming
judgment of God.
Sabbath March 24th 1849.
We had a sweet and very interesting
meeting with the brethren at Topshop
Maine. the Holy Ghost was poured out
upon us and I was taken off in the
spirit to the city of the living God.
There I was shown that the commandments
of God and the testimony of Jesus Christ
relating to the shut door could not be
separated and that the time for the
commandments of God to shine out with
all their importance and for God's
people to be tried on the Sabbath truth
was when the door was opened in the most
holy place of the heavenly sanctuary
where the ark is containing the ten
commandments.
This door was not opened until the
mediation of Jesus was finished in the
holy place of the sanctuary in 1844.
Then Jesus rose up and shut the door in
the holy place and opened the door in
the most holy and passed within the
second veil where he now stands by the
ark and where the faith of Israel now
reaches.
I saw that Jesus had shut the door in
the holy place and no man can open it.
And that he had opened the door of the
most holy and no man can shut it. And
that since Jesus has opened the door in
the most holy place which contains the
ark, the commandments have it have uh
been shining out of uh to God's people
and they are being tested on the Sabbath
question.
I saw that at the present time on the
Sabbath could or I saw that the present
test on the Sabbath could not come until
the mediation of Jesus in the holy place
was finished and he had passed within
the second veil. Therefore, Christians
who fell asleep before the door was
opened in the most holy when the
midnight cry was finished at the 7month
1844 and had not kept the true Sabbath
now rest in hope. For they had not the
light and the test on the Sabbath, which
we now have since that door was opened.
Pause really quick. In passing, you'll
remember we've looked at this before and
talked about how she contradicts herself
because she claims that the Sabbath was
a test in all ages elsewhere. But I
digress. Continuing,
I saw that Satan was tempting some of
God's people on this point, the Sabbath.
because so many good Christians have
fallen asleep in the triumphs of faith
and have not kept the true Sabbath. They
were uh doubting about it being a test
for us now.
I saw that the enemies of the present
truth have been trying to open the door
of the holy place that Jesus has shut
and to close the door of the most holy
place which he opened in 1844 where the
ark is containing the two tables of
stone on which are written the ten
commandments by the finger of Jehovah.
Satan is now using every device in this
ceiling time to keep the mind of minds
of God's people from the present sealing
truth and to cause them to waver. I saw
a covering that God was drawing over his
people to protect them in the time of
trouble. And every soul that was decided
on the truth and was pure in heart was
to be covered with the covering of
Almighty God.
Satan knew this and was at work in
mighty power to keep the minds of as
many as possible uh to keep the minds of
as many as he possibly could unsettled
and wavering on the truth. I saw that
the mysterious knocking in New York and
other places was the power of Satan and
that such things would be more and more
common clothed in a religious garb to
lull the deceived to more security and
to draw the minds of God's people if
possible to those things and cause them
to doubt the teachings and power of the
Holy Ghost.
I saw that Satan was working through
agents in a number of ways. He was at
work through ministers who have rejected
the truth and are given over to strong
delusions to believe a lie that they
might be damned.
H
while they were preaching or praying,
some would fall prostrate and helpless.
Not by the power of the Holy Ghost, no,
but by the power of Satan breathed upon
these agents and threw them to the
people. Ah, so these ministers were
actually influenced by Satan.
Some professed Adventists who had
rejected the present truth, aka the shut
door, the closing of the holy place and
the opening of the most holy place door.
Some professed Adventists who had
rejected the present truth while
preaching, praying, or in conversation
used memeism to gain adherence. And the
people would rejoice in this influence,
for they thought it was the Holy Ghost.
And even some that used it were so far
in the darkness and deception of the
devil that they thought it was the power
of God given them uh given them to
exercise. They had made God altogether
such as one of themselves and had valued
his power as a thing of not.
Some of these agents of Satan were
affecting the bodies of some of the
saints, those that they could not
deceive and draw away from the truth by
a satanic influence. Oh, that all could
get a view of it as God revealed it to
me, that they might know more of the ws
of Satan and be on their guard. I saw
that Satan was at work in these ways to
distract, deceive, and draw away God's
people. Just now in the ceiling time, I
saw some who were not standing stiffly
for present truth. Their knees were
trembling and their feet were sliding
because they were not firmly planted on
the truth. And the covering of Almighty
God could not be drawn over them while
they were thus trembling.
Ah, so if you were doubting 1844 as an
early little flockian, because they were
the little flock at this time, you
weren't going to be covered by the
protection of God. You were going to
fall prey to these ministers that were
breathing the influence of Satan on
their congregants.
Satan was trying his every art to hold
them where they were until the ceiling
was passed and covering drawn over God's
people and they left out without a
shelter from the burning wrath of God in
the seven last plagues.
God has begun to draw his covering over
his people and it will very soon be
drawn over all who are to have a shelter
in the day of slaughter.
God will work in power for his people
and Satan will be permitted to work
also.
I saw that the mysterious signs and
wonders and false reformations would
increase and spread. The reformations
that were shown me were not reformations
from error to truth, but from bad to
worse. For those who professed a change
of heart, had only wrapped about them a
religious garb which covered up their
iniquity of a wicked heart. Some
appeared to have been really converted
so as to deceive God's people.
Oh, they weren't really converted.
But if their hearts could be seen, they
would appear as black as ever.
My accompanying angel bade me look for
the travail of soul for
sinners. As used to be, I looked but
could not see it.
What's that? For the time of their
salvation
is passed.
Did you get that?
Do you follow along with what's being
said there?
Ah, so on March 24, 1849,
Ellen claims that God showed her the
truth regarding the shutd door of mercy.
This was after their initial pivot. So,
a little bit of a backstory for you
guys. We've done this in a longer video.
You can go check it out for the more
full in-depth breakdown of the supposed
second vision of February 1845.
That's what Mrs. Berdick is referring
to. That was the shut door vision.
By this point in 1849, they've pivoted.
You've now had well one door shut, but
another door opened.
Oh,
and Ellen claims in 1849 that God showed
her the truth regarding the shut door of
mercy.
But the Christians of the day that
rejected this mess,
Allen says they were trying to open the
door to the holy place and close the
door of the most holy. Aka they rejected
this entire framework that the little
flock had concocted. And as such, God
supposedly showed Ellen that they were
in error for doing so.
But she also claimed that this was the
ceiling time.
[Music]
The Sabbath test was happening.
Ah, the sealing period was taking place.
So God showed Ellen that the Sabbath
seal was actually being issued during
their day.
If the SDA church will tell you that,
no, we don't believe the sealing times
happened yet, only when the Sunday law
is issued.
But God also showed her Satan's working.
Namely, that Satan was working through
agents, ministers, in a number of ways.
He was at work through the ministers who
had rejected this truth, aka the 1844
mess. And those ministers were given
over to strong delusions to believe a
lie that they might be damned.
Oh, but she said in 1874
that she never used such language of
anyone, no matter how sinful they were.
She never had a vision regarding such
not just about the world as a whole but
she says of anyone period.
But these ministers that were being used
by Satan also had signs and wonders that
supposedly were wooing people but it was
actually the power of the devil to
deceive them. False reformations.
Their hearts were black as ever.
all of this because they rejected the
little flock's 1844 silliness, mind you.
And that she was she was shown that some
weren't standing stiffly for present
truth. You know, people that are
starting to utilize their critical
thinking that okay, I think we've been
duped.
Their knees were trembling. Their feet
were sliding because they weren't firmly
planted on the present truth. And the
covering of Almighty God couldn't be
drawn over them while they were
trembling.
So, Satan was trying to keep them
trembling before the ceiling was
finished.
Meaning, you weren't covered and
protected by God if you didn't go along
with the 1844 mess because that was
supposedly light from God. And if you
rejected it, you rejected God's leading.
Remember the path vision.
She then ended by saying that the
covering of God was underway and Satan
was seeking to keep people deceived
until that was over. false reformations
would happen, but it wasn't God behind
it. Some appeared to be converted, but
if their hearts could be seen black as
ever.
Oh,
sounds like the conversion of sinners.
But it's not actual conversions because
if you're on board with 1844 and Ellen's
vision supposedly confirming that, well,
then you're not going to get sealed.
Your conversion's fake.
But then the final line that we read,
my accompanying angel bade me look for
the travail of soul for sinners as used
to be. I looked but could not see it.
For the time of their salvation
is passed.
Ah right.
Because that is what Ellen claimed to be
shown in vision. Yes, she absolutely did
use that language about the world being
damned and doomed and claimed God showed
it to her. Lucinda Berdick was not just
making this up.
Now, I mentioned
the path vision December 1844. This is
documented for us in the word to the
little flock. Notice
quote
while praying at the family altar the
Holy Ghost fell on me and seemed to be
rising higher and higher far above the
dark world.
I turned to look for the Advent people
in the world but could not find them.
When a voice said to me, "Look again and
look a little higher."
At this I raised my eyes and saw a
straight and narrow path cast up high
above the world. On this path the Advent
people were traveling to the city which
was at the farther end of the path.
They had a bright light set up behind
them at the first end of the path which
an angel told me was the midnight cry.
This light shone all along the path and
gave light for their feet so they might
not stumble.
And if they kept their eyes fixed on
Jesus who was just before them leading
them to the city, they were safe.
So she says she was shown in vision that
the Millerites were on the path to
heaven. So she means by Adventist at
this point. SDA church hasn't been born
yet formally. There was a bright light
ahead of the path which the angel told
her was the midnight cry. That was the
initial me message involving William
Miller. first angel's message.
This light was coming from God
supposedly and it was allowing them to
keep their eyes fixed on Jesus. She
continues,
"But soon some grew weary and they said
the city was a great way off and they
expected to have entered it before. Then
Jesus would encourage them by raising
his glorious right arm and from his arm
came a glorious light which waved over
the advent band and they shouted
hallelujah. Others rashly denied the
light behind them and said that it was
not God that had led them out so far.
The light behind them went out, leaving
their feet in perfect darkness. And they
stumbled and got their eyes off the mark
and lost sight of Jesus, and fell off
the path
down into the dark and wicked world
below.
It was just as impossible for them to
get on the path again and go to the city
as
all the wicked world which God
had rejected.
They fell all the way along the path one
after another until we heard the voice
of God like many waters which gave us
the day and hour of Jesus's coming.
Close quote.
So when some Millerites grew weary after
the great disappointment, Jesus
supposedly encouraged them by giving
them more light through Ellen White. I
guess Ellen Harmon at this time that was
supposed to guide them and keep them on
the path. Some accepted it, but others
rejected it and said God wasn't behind
all that. to which Ellen says, "The
light then left them, leaving them in
perfect darkness, and they stumbled off
the path down into the dark and wicked
world
that God had rejected."
Never mind the fact that she claims they
were shown the day and the hour and the
defenses that well later she claims she
didn't remember it.
Ay, the Adventist God who is just the
world's worst communicator apparently.
He's apparently all knowing, too. So, he
knows he's going to give her the day and
the hour and she's going to forget it.
But he's still giving it to her for a
reason to then tell people that she was
given the day in the Yeah,
never mind all that. She contradicted
herself in 1874 where she claimed she
never claimed to be shown in vision that
the world was lost or salvation was up.
She never under any circumstances used
such language about anyone no matter how
sinful they may have been.
Adventist loved to point to the 1874 and
83 statements to claim see she said she
never said this.
Yet the evidence shows she was either
forgetful or lying.
I don't know if she was getting soft
upstairs or what, but
if God supposedly showed this to you,
based on what we see from God
interacting with mere mortals, she would
not have forgotten this. Ellen White's
interactions interactions with God are
nothing like you see any person in
scripture ever who interacts with God.
Never.
This idea that it's just like, oh yeah,
just she's just going on a VIP tour to
heaven. just she's sitting there in the
the Bates living room and just whoosh.
She's just I'm in heaven. Oh, it's just
daisies and rainbows and it's just like
what are you even talking about?
Supposedly in the presence of incredible
holiness and it's just like a a a rose
garden, the rose garden path just but
no, she bore God's name falsely,
violating the third commandment
repeatedly and claimed this all came
from God when it didn't. Lucinda Berdick
was not lying. Her claim was perfectly
in line with all of Ellen's statements
regarding Christians being Babylon,
God's angry with them, yada yada. It's
perfectly in line with the supposed
February 1845 second vision. So Miles
Grant and Listen to Berdick's claims
weren't some anomalous out of the blue
type thing. But an even stronger
evidence of Ellen White not being a true
prophet is not just her failed
forthtellings or contradictions,
but her theological blunders.
Notice
we've looked at this before.
We're going to look at one example here
and there are we could spend the whole
night on this, but we got to listen to
our SDA scholar friends. Quote,
"As anciently the sins of the people
were placed by faith upon the sin
offering and through its blood
transferred in figure to the earthly
sanctuary,
so in the new covenant, the sins of the
repentant are by faith placed upon
Christ and transferred in fact to the
heavenly sanctuary."
Close quote.
So she claims as SDA theology teaches
that in the old covenant sins were
transferred into the holy place daily.
The penitent Israelite would show up
with their sacrifice for their sins,
bring it to the priest, confess over the
animal their sins. The animal would then
be slain and the blood taken into the
holy place to be sprinkled before the
veil to rest there in type until the day
of atonement
which was once a year. This supposedly
transferred the penitent Israelites sins
in type to the sanctuary to then be
dealt with on the day of atonement.
Well, in the new covenant they say the
same thing happens but without the
repeated sacrifices.
You confess your sins upon Christ, the
single sacrifice, and they're
transferred by his blood in type to the
heavenly sanctuary where Jesus currently
is. And he's doing the day of atonement
work of cleansing the sanctuary by
dealing with sin.
She expounds upon this further where she
writes patriarchs and prophets page 354.
The most important part of the daily
ministration
was the service performed in behalf of
who?
Individuals.
The repentant sinner brought his
offering to the door of the tabernacle
and placing his hand upon the victim's
head, confessing his sins, thus in
figure, transferring them from himself
to the innocent sacrifice.
By his own hand, the animal was then
slain and the blood was carried by the
priest into the holy place and sprinkled
before the veil.
The blood was carried by the priest into
the holy place and sprinkled before the
veil.
Individual penitent Israelites daily
ministry
behind that veil which was the ark
containing the law that the sinner had
transgressed. By the ceremony, the sin
was through the blood transferred in
figure to the sanctuary.
In some cases,
the blood was not taken into the holy
place, but the flesh was then to be
eaten by the priest as Moses directed
the sons of Aaron, saying, "God hath
given it to you to be or given it."
Yeah. Given it you to bear the iniquity
of the congregation. Leviticus 10:17.
Both ceremonies alike
symbolized the transfer of the sin from
the penitant to the sanctuary.
close quote. No,
this whole thing is badly broken.
For starters, there is no concept in
scripture of blood being a transference
vehicle to move sin around.
The blood of Christ is always described
as cleansing, removing sin, etc., not
transferring it around. But more
importantly,
that's not what happened in the daily
ministration.
Leviticus 4 is clear.
Outside of the day of atonement, there
were only two times that the blood was
taken into the holy place.
When the priest sinned,
when the entire Israelite congregation
sinned unintentionally.
Go look it up.
The daily ministration for penitent
Israelites did not involve taking the
blood of the sacrifice into the holy
place and sprinkling it before the veil
which not only ruins their entire
sanctuary model but demonstrates Ellen
White contradicts God's word despite
claiming in the same book Patriarchs and
Prophets which she claimed is barricaded
by a thus sayeth the Lord
that whatever contradicts God's word, we
may be sure proceeds from Satan.
By her own standard, this then came from
Satan. And like we saw earlier, her
writings supposedly bear the test of
investigation and have the signate mark
of either Satan or God because they
can't work in co-artnership, all or
nothing. They bear the mark of Satan.
This doesn't even get into her falsely
claiming that Jesus was inaugurated as a
priest at his ascension, which
contradicts Hebrews 2, John 17, and
elsewhere, which are clear that the
priest must offer up the sacrifice.
Jesus being the great high priest and
great sacrifice that offers up himself
at Calvary, which was before the
ascension.
His high priestly prayer in John 17,
that's before the ascension.
All of her christoologgical statements
and countless other theological blunders
that all demonstrate without question,
no, Ellen White was a false prophet, the
daughter of William Miller, another
false prophet.
So, these have been this platform's
primary formal objections in this area.
One, the SDA church does not affirm
solos scriptor.
Soloscriptura is the belief that
scripture is the only infallible
rule of faith and practice.
It is not nudcriptura or biblicism which
is Bible only.
This who cares about history who cares
about the church fathers.
Solos scriptura also demands a belief in
the inherency of scripture not just its
infallibility.
The SDA church rejects inherency, claims
the Bible has all sorts of errors
because they have to make scripture be
on par with Ellen White's writings,
which are full of errors.
That's actually how many of them seek to
to defend the things I pointed out.
Anytime she's wrong, notice appeal to,
well, she wasn't perfect. That's
supposed to be the the Trump card. But
no, they do not affirm solos scriptor.
They need to stop confusing people and
claiming that they do. I don't care if
they don't affirm it, but my contention
in that regard has been they need to own
up that they don't and just be
forthright regarding what they do
actually believe and then defend that.
In conjunction with this, the SDA church
teaches that the writings of Ellen White
are the infallible interpreter of
scripture.
This is what numerous primary source
documents state like we saw. And until
they are willing to renounce their
pioneers, Ellen herself, their own
scholars, and their own publications,
this has not and will not change. The
third, without Ellen White, the entire
framework of Adventism collapses.
As GI Butler, so simply put it, she's
the keystone to the SDA arch. That
falls, the entire thing collapses. Their
special message and the mission that
only they have goes away. and
Adventism's identity as the end times
remnant of God vanishes.
And four, Ellen White does not pass the
test of a biblical prophet,
which sumearily refutes Adventism,
removing the keystone from their arch
and the whole thing crumbles apart. And
we didn't even scratch the surface with
the clear ex, you know, with the clear
example that we did look at or examples
I should say. Our website speaks for
itself.
If the SDA church does not like the
canonical standard of a prophet being
utilized to test Ellen White, then they
shouldn't utilize her like a canonical
prophet.
This is another common defense they try
to give. When you demonstrate from
scripture that she fails,
they'll say, "No, no, no. She's not an
addition to the canon of scripture."
It's what Dr. Lake says in his book. Of
course, you can't use the same standard
that was used for canonical prophets
that were writing scripture. you need to
use the New Testament standard for the
New Testament gift of prophecy.
Well, then the SDA church needs to stop
utilizing her like a canonical prophet
and instead utilize her like a local
prophet whose gifting was for the
present time and ceases when the person
dies.
That's not how she functions for the SDA
church. She functions just like she was
still alive today. and her writings,
according to her, were authored by the
Holy Spirit, no differently than the
Bible. In fact, she literally says this
of her own writings, and it's the quote
that shows on the loading screen of the
Ellen White writings website. Notice
from selected messages, book three, the
chapter being titled after Ellen White's
death.
This is from starting on page 76, the
first three paragraphs on the page.
Ellen White's writings to continue to
witness. I'm to trace this testimony on
paper that should I fall asleep in
Jesus, the witness to the truth might
still be born, to speak to the end.
Abundant light has been given to our
people in these last days. Whether or
not my life is spared, my writings will
constantly speak, and their work will go
forward as long as time shall last. My
writings are kept on file in the office.
And even though I should not live, these
words that have been given to me by the
Lord will still have life and will speak
to the people.
Messages to be of greater force after
prophet's death.
Physically, I've always been as a broken
vessel. And yet, in my old age, the Lord
continues to move upon me by his Holy
Spirit to write the most important books
that have ever come before the churches
and the world.
The Lord is evidencing
what he can do through weak vessels.
The life that he spares, I will use to
his glory. And when he may see fit to
let me rest, his messages shall be of
even more vital force than when the
frail instrumentality through whom they
were delivered was living.
Close quote.
Not the Bible. No, no, no. Her writings
are the most important books that have
ever come before the churches and the
world.
Yeah. Don't tell me this movement does
not exalt this woman's writings. It's
why I'm constantly citing them. I didn't
choose this path for the SDA church.
Adventists, I didn't ascribe divine
status. I didn't write these words. They
did.
Adventists can b and scoff. I hear more
about Ellen White here than I do
anywhere else. Well, I'm glad I could be
of service.
Doesn't matter about your own personal
opinion. We're dealing with the
organization here.
I care about the system in terms of
critique and engagement and analyzing.
I didn't choose this path for the SDA
church. They did. They are the ones
making these insane claims.
We have the theological God particle,
God's mind, the theory of everything,
the antidote to theological division,
the equivalent of what Stephen Hawking
called the God particle. But why are you
critiquing us? Why are you being so
critical of us?
Hello.
Who else is making such a statement?
It's like what in the world are are have
you lost your marbles?
Like did your brain fall out when you
were walking up the stairs or what?
When you make insane statements like
this, folks, when you exalt a woman who
you claim the writings, the writings,
not just the conflict of the ages
series, her writings, divinely inspired,
and she's making statements like that,
and you tell us we have to have her to
interpret the Bible. Yeah, you bet you
we're going to be critical. But there
you go. She still functions as if she
were alive, not like a local prophet,
but one whose writings continue to give
revelation after she's passed.
All of the discussion around models of
inspiration and whether it was word
dictation or thought inspiration or
mechanical dictation, those are all just
distractions from the primary point. Dr.
Lake loves to bl bring up bring up those
arguments. He does it in his book. the
old, you know, these these critics, they
hold to this real rigid view of
inspiration.
That's the problem. They have this real
rigid view of inspiration. Yeah. It's a
real rigid view of inspiration uh that
that creates the the fact that she uh
just outright contradicts the Bible.
Yeah. It's it's my real rigid view of
inspiration that caused Ellen White to
uh contradict Leviticus chapter 4.
I don't care what form of inspiration
you affirm. It doesn't negate that Ellen
White regularly contradicts the Bible
and claimed the stuff came from God.
That disqualifies her. She claimed to be
shown the stuff in vision from God that
wasn't correct. Like that the time of
salvation was up and those who rejected
their early 1844 hysteria fell off the
path into the wicked world that God had
rejected. So, let's hear if Dr. Lake
interacts with any of these objections.
Because remember this is supposed to be
a response to this platform.
[Music]
For our final fundamental belief
section, we'll be covering multiple
questions while examining your book
Ellen White under fire and the 18th
fundamental belief which reads as
follows. The scriptures testify that one
of the gifts of the Holy Spirit is
prophecy. This gift is an identifying
mark of the remnant church and we
believe it was manifested in the
ministry of Ellen G. White. Her writings
speak with prophetic authority and
provide comfort, guidance, instruction,
and correction to the church. They also
make it clear that the Bible is a
standard by which all teaching and
experience must be tested. So, Dr. Lake,
the subtitle for your book, Ellen White
Under Fire, is identifying the mistakes
of her critics. This naturally begs the
question, what exactly are the alleged
mistakes of Ellen White's critics? What
is the state of Ellen White criticisms
today?
Of course, that's the answer to that is
is would be a full orbed presentation,
but uh for this purposes, we're just
we're just giving as concise as possible
as answers to these. But basically in a
nutshell, the issue I find with critics
repeatedly, past and present is a lack
of context in the charges that they
make. So often and in recent literature
I've read, the same thing happens again.
They'll cite a sentence by Ellen White
and read into it. Here is a heretical
teaching without examining its context.
Not a word about the paragraph or the
page that it's in. the flow of thought
of Ellen White. And by doing that, you
can read something into a sentence
that's completely foreign to the
author's ideas. People do that with the
Bible all the time. And I find that's
what critics repeatedly do with Ellen
White. Context. Context is the key.
We've got to read the literary context
as well as the historical context.
Yeah. Sorry, Dr. Lake. This old excuse
isn't going to work here. Okay.
Have I ever cited a single sentence of
Ellen White? Yep. Let's go look at the
context. Okay. Let's see if that Let's
see if that's what's happening. Okay.
Sometimes I'm doing it for brevity's
sake or we read almost an entire
manuscript like we just did earlier.
We're dealing with entire swads of the
woman's writings on this platform. her,
not just her, but all sorts of SDA
source documentation across the board.
You yourself already recognized in the
past part answering Adventisms dealing
with SDA systematic theology, sir. A
system that we're told is the equivalent
of the theological God particle.
Supposed to be the most revelatory
system that God himself ever gave to the
world.
Yeah. We're not just dealing with small
snippets out of context here and there.
That's why these streams are 3 4 hours
long, sir. 80 hours a week prepping
materials, getting sources together.
I've stated repeatedly, the reason I
take such an assertive approach. Well,
it's for numerous reasons, but one being
that I stand by my homework. I didn't
look off my neighbors, sir, and then try
and turn that in. I did the assignment
myself.
But I'm just curious, Dr. Blake, um,
do you not think that we've heard these
claims a million times at this point?
You You think that maybe, just maybe,
we've actually spent some time analyzing
these statements and the defenses that
you guys give.
This is why I tell people that what
you're really saying when you say this
is you lack reading comprehension.
Because it doesn't matter how much we
read, how much examination is done. The
meaning is apparently real cryptic and
advanced.
That is unless you're, you know, in
support of Adventism,
then it's just crystal clear. It's just
obvious. Just, you know, it's like when
you cite it like you did in the the
previous part and you're going to do in
this part, you know, when you read a
paragraph, oh, it's just it can just
clearly be understood, right?
And Steven Boore is citing it, Doug
Bachelor's citing it, and the guys at
the Barri are citing it, and all these
scholars in their papers, they're, you
know, they're they're citing it with the
ellipsus. They're leaving out entire
portions of the text. But whenever
they're pulling out, you know, a
sentence here or there, Dr. Lake, and
they're using it in your guys's own
scholastic works that circulate in the
ivory tower of Adventism. Oh, it's just
just obvious, right?
Back in part two, Dr. Lake said that I
needed to be comprehensively read on
Adventism if I'm going to critique it.
Sir, just in these three parts alone,
I've cited more primary source
documentation than most Adventists will
read in their entire lifetime.
That's just a fact. That's not including
our website, which is chocked full of
hundreds
of primary sources
in their entirety and the countless
hours of other broadcasts where we've
utilized other sources that the website
might not.
Are there people who have misapplied and
taken things from Ellen White out of
context? You betcha. And I'm aware of
many of these arguments and I don't use
them. In fact, I'm on record actively
telling people which arguments not to
use.
Many of them, this is why you go to the
context, she's not claiming what people
think she's saying.
But that's not going to work across the
board, buddy. Sorry. It's not just a
trump card. The Adventist Church thinks
they have all these trump cards, you
know? It's like I call it the present
truth magic wand. It's just like anytime
there's a problem. It's like present
truth.
Oh, out of context.
Yeah, not going to work. But I've read
your book, sir. And you make the error
of assuming all critics of Adventism are
the same or that they all utilize the
same apologetic methodology and
argumentation. And I get it. Your book
is relatively old. You're going to talk
about that some.
But you assert all the critics you were
aware of at the time of writing it were
all recycling DM Canright's arguments
and that critics of Adventism are
basically the offspring of Canrite.
So I hope when you get to your real
response because Christopher told me
that this wasn't the real response.
You're probably going to put out a book
that you're going to make me pay to to
hear the response. I'm going to guess
that's fine.
happy to add it to my very expansive SDA
library, but just understand that's not
going to work here.
We will dunk on that so quickly because
I know Canr's arguments and I know
Canr's theology and I don't agree with
Krite on a lot of things. I ag I I
arrive at a lot of the same conclusions.
We use a different route to get there.
But sir, I would love to hear an
explanation of how what Ellen White said
in the present truth is out of context.
you know that we just read about 19
paragraphs of
that we did like a twohour stream on the
fe we went through it's like dude we
went through uh uh Mr. Olsen's in like
his entire breakdown of the shut door
problems, his paper that he put out when
he was the director at the White Estate.
We went through her entire manuscript.
We talked about how she saw a paper from
Turner and how she couldn't read cuz it
was giving her a headache even though
she was left alone with this shut door.
She'd never heard it from anyone else.
But uh oh, lo and behold, God gave her a
vision and it's exactly what was in this
paper that she was left alone with that
uh she didn't read.
Like, dude, give me a break. We just
read almost the entire letter. I would
love to hear how I've ignored context
regarding the blunders of of claiming
the Levitical priest daily took blood
into the holy place and sprinkled it
before the veil for penitent individual
Israelites despite this contradicting
Leviticus 4.
No, it's not out of context because
that's what you guys teach, not just
Ellen White. I'd love to hear how it's
out of context that Ellen White falsely
claimed that Christ was inaugurated as a
high priest at his ascension, which is
verbatim included in your guys' 24th
fundamental belief.
The problem with Ellen White,
the problems with Ellen White are not
all formally heretical issues, sir, but
contradictory ones as well.
We talk about source documentation.
Um, that is a term that is so important
and there's a lot that has already been
written dealing with all the issues with
regard to Ellen White and Adventist
teachings. Source documentation within
Adventist history and within the context
of Ellen White's writings is crucial.
There is more material that is coming
out. Advent Adventist scholars are
working on lots of material. There are
three major works coming out on the
issue of the triune God, the trinity
that need attention because of
misunderstandings within the church with
regard to the anti-trinitarianism
as well as misunderstandings outside in
charges of the critics. So there are
works to yet to come. There are in work
right now and that is going to bring
light to a lot of these issues. But
again and again it's going to be the
issue of context context. Context.
Context. I notice in in several of Miles
streams in the background there's a
statement that says context is king.
Well, I would agree with that. To
determine who really makes context king
is to is how they use the writings, for
example, the writings of Ellen White. Is
context really king in the charges
against Ellen White? My experience in
reading is that it's not.
Yeah, context is king. her.
Which is why I implore you to show me
where I've taken her out of context to
make her say something she's not saying.
I I keep asking for this from Adventists
and all we get is the standard. You're
inspired by Satan. You're angry. Yeah,
good job.
Great work.
So, how does that prove that Leviticus 4
doesn't say what it says? H how does
that prove that uh
Jesus was inaugurated to be a priest at
his ascension?
H how does that prove that uh scripture
is not clear that Christ put sin away at
the cross? That Christ is seated in
heaven that he's not wearing Levitical
priesthood garments.
How does that deal with the fact that uh
one of the promises of the new covenant
which you guys love to appeal to to say
see it says the law will be written on
our hearts. Yeah. Yeah. And in the next
verse it says, "And one of and on top of
that, God remembers our sins no more."
Oh, no. No, but he's he he's
investigating them. They're on record in
heaven. He not only remembers them, he's
investigating them.
I've talked about the internal versus
external critique on this platform many
times. 95% of the time, sir, I'm doing
an internal critique of Adventism, not
an external one. An internal critique is
where you do your exam from within the
worldview or system that you are
critiquing versus from the outside with
a differing foundation or worldview.
I reassume a great controversy worldview
when critiquing Adventism and I'm
showing internal inconsistencies
andor biblical contradictions.
Sometimes I do an external critique. It
depends on the context. But Dr. Blake,
this is when I knew for certain that you
hadn't done your homework. And
ironically,
you're the one that was talking about
needing to be comprehensively read. Sir,
primary sources are our thing here.
I I mean, you're just saying primary
sources, that's the key. I agree. That's
why we don't engage every Joe Schmo SDA
that demands we engage with them because
I already know your guys' MO. You'll
point to that after they get embarrassed
and to your chagrin, you'll be left
having to say, "Well, that wasn't an
official representative of SDA theology
and all the other excuses that I've
heard and learned from." That's why I've
disarmed that silly tactic by not even
engaging with them and reserving that
type of engagement for the likes of
yourself and other qualified
spokespeople for SDA theology. The
problem is you guys won't publicly
engage face to face.
Nevertheless, yes, source documentation
is absolutely key, but no, you guys
haven't dealt with any of the problems.
This is another common claim SDA
scholarship makes and passes off to the
ley who then begin pariting it. All the
criticisms of Adventism have already
been dealt with in the primary source
documentation of the movement scholars.
And it's typically said to imply, "So
don't listen to the critics. Everything
they say has already been dealt with."
When no, it hasn't.
as has been shown repeatedly on this
platform, such as when Steve Dailyaly
was here and we looked at Alberto Tim's
lackluster response to Steve's book.
They'll call that a dealing with the
critics, but if you actually examine
what the critic is saying, the response
doesn't even deal with it. Just a bunch
of ad homonym, straw men, and red
herrings. He said, "Lots of material
about the subject on the Trinity is
coming out." Yeah. And I will I'll be
looking forward to this, sir. I will.
This I will really be looking forward
to.
I am champing at the bit to see these
works that deal with the issues this
platform's raised because I'll be
curious to see these new defenses and
how they pivot entirely off of what
Jerry Moon and others have put forth
regarding the subject wherein they admit
that the leading source for development
on this subject within Adventism came
from Ellen White's own progressive
understanding.
It's like are we really to believe sir
that these new works are going to pivot
off of that? Of course not. It'll be the
same old thing packaged in new language
to give it a facelift and make it more
palatable for the non-adventist and the
Adventist alike to try and dissuade
internal and external heat.
Dr. Lake, we've done over 15 hours of
video alone on this platform regarding
the Trinity. We've gone over Jerry
Moon's entire paper, listened to you
yourself explain the heavenly trio,
looked at Ellen White exhaustively on
the subject, looked at numerous SDA
pioneers, the development of the
teaching, what the current teaching is,
and on and on and on, all utilizing
primary source documentation.
The Trinity is one of my breadandut
subjects, sir. I would be glad to have a
public-f facing high-level theological
discussion on this subject with you or
any other qualified SDA scholar on the
subject for that matter.
So, let's stop with the out of context
excuse, okay? It it it's old. It's just
old. It's like an old It's just a tired
argument, man. It's just every time I
hear that, I'm just like, dude,
yeah, you have no answers. It doesn't
address anything. demonstrate how and
where I've done this. And in the
process, let's see if you took the time
to consider the context in which I'm
using whatever quote I'm using. Cuz
that's another problem you guys have.
You'll respond to critics by pointing
out things we object to, but then you
don't correctly represent why we're
objecting.
You'll say we're using a quote to say
something we're not claiming, which is a
form of a straw man. Because then you
and then you guys will attack the way a
quote is being used. But that isn't
actually why it's being cited.
Like the infamous, "The man Christ Jesus
was not the Lord God Almighty quote." I
cite this repeatedly to show Christians
a statement that's not compatible with
Orthodox Trinitarianism, no matter which
way you slice it. I know all the
defenses. We have an article on this on
our website laying out the various
defenses that SDAs use. Yet SDA scholars
and apologists will cite me saying this
to try and claim that my argument is
that Ellen White said Jesus isn't God.
Uh, no, that's not why I'm citing that
quote. Some people might be, but that's
not me. In fact, I'm constantly
explaining to Christians that scaling
the language barrier is a must with SDAs
because they'll use terms like God,
person, being, but they don't mean the
same thing Christians do.
That's a perfect example. They'll
highlight that quote and say, "No, no,
Ellen White did teach Jesus is God.
That's not why I'm citing it." And I
know that she claimed that. What do you
guys mean by the term God? Oh, well,
according to Jerry Moon in his paper,
you have one god in Adventism because,
well, unlike the the pantheon of gods,
they're united in a mission. There's no
conflict or cross purposes. But if there
were, that'd be polytheism,
right? You guys don't use the word the
same way we do.
So, I hope you and your cohorts do your
due diligence this time, and I look
forward to these new proofs and
responses that hopefully engage with
what's actually being said. Um, the
thing you yourself are claiming critics
of Adventism don't do.
So, that's where the issue comes. Now,
let me give a background of of
criticisms criticisms of Ellen White. My
book was written Ellen White under fire
14 years ago. There's been a lot of
change since that time. And there was
that book was in response to a wave of
charges that had been um placed on the
internet. The internet was newer in
those days and it was gaining momentum
and the critical
presentations against Ellaw White had
gained a lot of momentum. So I was
responding to that. Since then the group
proclamation for example has continued
with a steady stream. Uh I think that in
terms within Adventist circles, their
influence was not as big over the last
decade, but there's been a resurgence.
Uh they've they've broken out of their
own crowd and are now going on
evangelical apologetic sites with their
same narrative uh again against
Adventist. And also I think the
answering adventism by Miles Miles
Kettlesen that is a well done site in
terms of the way it's marketed, the way
he runs it. It's gaining a lot of
traction. Uh, of course, the recent
publications of Steve Dailyaly against
Ellen White. Uh, these this is what I
see as a new wave of charges against
Adventism. So, I find these charges I
don't find them alarming. Um, it's been
around a long time. It's just coming
forth in a new configuration and that
type of thing. And there are some new
charges that have never been leveled
before against Ellen White as well as
Adventists. But I find them to be a good
opportunity for us to go back and study
for every Adventist to study. Adventists
will often respond with, you know,
texting and messages on some of mile
streams for example and and in other
places. And that often that that is not
really helpful when you put yourself in
an environment like that where what you
say can be criticized and and downplayed
and manipulated. What we need to do is
listen to the charges and go and find
the sources that are referenced and
study them for ourselves. And I I know
in my own experience that has increased
my faith in Adventism. I I listen
carefully to the charges against Ellen
White.
and I'm always listening for how they're
used, the context in which they use
them, and I go study them out and find
responses to it. And that is a most
helpful exercise. I believe that's what
all Adventists should be doing now in
responding to this new wave of charges.
The criticisms are not going away and
they're probably going to get even more
intense. That should challenge us to
study for ourselves.
Yeah, Dr. Lake, I hope you understand
some of your students, plural,
have reached out to us.
They're listening.
I know that you uh talk about me at your
Sabbath school. I know that you talk
about me in your classroom, but you
don't use my name. You refer to me as
this new wave.
It's a new wave. They're using all the
same criticisms they had before, but
it's it's just a new buttoned up. You
know, sir, you guys would know all about
that.
We just looked at contours of Adventist
sotiology in the last part, which was a
book he told me I needed to be read up
on if I'm going to critique Adventism. I
hold up the book because I have the book
and my central charge of that book is
exactly that that's what that book is
which is why we specifically cited from
Ellen White to show the book is
literally just paring Ellen White but in
a new Christian veneer to make it seem
more uh obfuscatory and uh a little less
um there's just more plausible
deniability. You guys just put it in
scholastic bloation word speak. Give me
a break. But thank you for recognizing
that yes, not all the criticisms are the
same, sir. He mentioned Proclamation
Magazine. Yes, I love Rich and Colleen
Tinker, Nikki Stevenson. I'm friends
with them and former Adventist.
It was a godsend early on after leaving
Adventism as a source that God used to
encourage me. But I'm going to give you
a heads up, Dr. Leon. I'm not former
Adventist.
Answering Adventism holds to a much
different theology than they do. I'm
united with them in the fundamentals. We
arrive at many of the same conclusions
regarding Adventism, but we differ on
secondary doctrinal matters and the
methodology by which we arrive at the
same conclusions.
The Sabbath, for example, you guys are
going to have a hell of a time trying to
engage this platform on that subject if
you come prepared with the arguments
that you use for their position, which
is the majority former Adventist
position.
Same with Steve Dailyaly. I love Steve.
He's a friend of the show. He's going to
be on here next week actually to talk
about 1919.
But I don't think SDA scholarship
recognizes that answering Adventism is
not doing anything anyone before us has.
And I think by the time that you guys
get it, it's going to be too late.
Folks, go back over a year ago, watch
some of those streams from over a year
ago. I said this. I said by the time
they try to put out the stops, this
train is going to be going so fast it's
going to blow through it like a paper
barrier. Our
website had over half a million page
views this last month.
Yes, our website is marketed very well
thanks to Chris for that and his
god-given skill set. We're ranking
higher in accessibility ratings and
metrics over the SDA church's own
website. Our website's not even a year
old.
It's still indexing some things, which
means it's only going to continue
climbing the rankings higher and higher
and higher, and there's nothing you guys
can do about it. Eventually, people are
going to go in to search stuff for the
SDA church and answering Adventism is
going to pop up.
Folks, I was not kidding. I told you
guys over a year ago, we're just getting
started.
This isn't a game.
I I we it's like every week we get SDAs
reaching out. It's like, dude, this
isn't a game. I'm We're not kidding
around.
We're not just goofing off online.
We got our nonprofit status, by the way,
folks.
Full steam ahead.
And I've told you this was something no
one else before us has ever undertaken.
I was not being sensational. I was not
joking. Dr. Lake, yes, you guys are in
serious trouble, sir.
I'm not being sensational.
I hope I've made that clear at this
point
because my apologetic against Adventism
is not that of Steve Dailyaly, former
Adventist, DM Canrite, Dez Ford, Dale
Ratzife, or any of the other critics.
There is absolutely some overlap, but
this is not one of them. It's not a
onetoone.
And this new wave is absolutely united
in one mind and one spirit on the gospel
of Jesus Christ as Paul commands in
Philippians 1. We worship the same God
and preach the same gospel which is
ultimately what unites us. Not secondary
doctrinal differences unlike Adventism
where it's a splintered mess of
divisions over every little thing. It's
like man you part your hair on the wrong
side in some SDA circles and it's
cursings and damnation. But he said he
doesn't find these charges alarming.
They've been around for a long time, but
there are some new ones. Yes, I look
forward to you all engaging with these
as I can name uh numerous charges that
I've made that I haven't heard others
making
because again, we don't all have the
same system of theology. So, some of us
are going to have different objections
for different reasons. Same objections
sometimes, but still for different
reasons
as it pertains to external critiques.
Shoot, I could probably name hundreds.
hundreds.
I don't even often do external
critiques. I do internal ones to avoid
the sort of visceral responses like,
"But that's Calvinism."
instead of actually dealing with what's
presented from scripture.
You know, I I'll I'll present something
and and criticize something. And they
love to just That's Calvinism. It's
Calvinism.
Apparently, Calvinism has a monopoly now
on thinking the atonement is completed.
You are going to have to train up your
your leoty sir a lot better than where
they currently are. I would love to have
a public debate with any sort of formal
adventist represent representative on
the Sabbath. I would love to do that.
Bring 10 people. Bring the greatest
theologians you have up in Tacoma Park.
Not Joe Schmo SDA. We get all sorts of
those. They demand we debate them in the
comments. Yeah. Get out of here. You You
don't You are not cut out for this,
buddy. But I would love to debate that
subject. Bring your Sabbath arguments
that you guys have been using.
And what we'll do is we'll make sure the
openings are about 25 minutes so I can
do a small historical overview and show
people, look, this is where these guys
stole their arguments from my spiritual
ancestors. But then they just tried to
use one added argument, but they were
all wrong about the day. We agree with
all them about all of their arguments
about the Sabbath, but they were wrong
about the day.
Oh, and it's the seal of God's law, and
it's eternal, not just in the sense that
uh it has moral imperatives, and that's
a reflection of who God is. No, no, no.
It's so eternal that even the angels are
keeping it. Yeah. Show up to show up to
debate uh on that subject and bring the
arguments you guys have used in the past
and let's see how that goes. But I do
appreciate Dr. Lakes's balanced approach
regarding comment wars. He's exactly
correct. We typically respond to obtuse
comments for the sake of others who may
see them, but Dr. Lake, this is also why
I solicited a a discussion with you face
to face and even offered to come down to
your office to do it there so you could
see there wasn't any funny business
going on yet you guys won't do it. And
then I have to constantly get saddled
with hearing SDAs who say you never talk
to to accurate representatives. Well
then I'll talk to the ones who will and
then it's well that's just some crackpot
SDA off in the corner somewhere. Yeah,
damned if I do, damned if I don't. which
is again why we just ignore those people
now because it takes time to do all
that. It ends up being a waste of time
anyways because then you guys just make
an excuse that I was picking on some
lowhanging fruit when no that's just the
only person that would show up.
But again, I look forward to when the
criticisms are actually meaningfully
engaged. We're constantly told that we
don't look at the context. So, I'll be
looking forward to hearing SDA
scholarship address the problems by
making sure they understand the context
of the criticism, why a certain
statement is being utilized, and then
demonstrating why utilizing sound
biblical exesus. Remember, they only
accept the historical grammatical method
of interpretation.
So, let's see you do those things while
utilizing the HGM
and prove that you're correct through
doing that. But, Dr. Like if this exists
and this is a response video, why
haven't you provided even a single
example of this?
If this is what's going on, like you
claim, oh, it's always out of context.
They're not looking at this or or that.
Why have you done what almost all SDAs
do?
You make this claim, but you don't
provide a single example of it. It's
just happening all the time. You should
have just a plethora of examples. All my
homework is publicly out there. Go to
our website.
You said primary source documentation is
key. Yet, I'm the only one that's
actually cited any for my claims
regarding Adventism.
Why didn't you give the audience even
one single example of me doing this? I
mean, I know you have time constraints,
but we have hundreds of articles to
choose from and countless ones
pertaining to Ellen White. You couldn't
provide even one single citation to
support this claim. Again, I'm looking
forward to the new scholastic works
coming out, particularly with regards to
what I presented in part one of the
series.
Dr. Lake, thank you for outlining the
landscape of Ellen White criticisms. And
with that being said, may you please
clarify the purpose of your book, Ellen
White Under Fire, as some might feel
that this text did not address the main
criticisms of Ellen White in her
writings. What is your response? Yeah,
glad to to respond to that because I've
heard it a few times and and and more
recently uh that my book it didn't deal
with the shut door, the plagiarism, the
myriad of charges. It's Ellen White on a
fire. It's a response to all the
charges. Actually, that's not the
purpose of the book. The book is often
criticized for something it's not trying
to do. Um it it is simply to lay out the
underlying issues issues of history of
the criticisms, revelation, inspiration
in Ellen White's experience, the
authority of Ellen White in relationship
to the authority of scripture and of
course interpretation and the overall
themes in her writings. That's the the
issues that the book was dealing with
the nature of felicious arguments
argumentation as well. So, it's not
really meant to
dive into things such as the shut door.
It may mention that, but uh the book
should be addressed by what it's trying
to do. I remember Miles, I heard him
complaining on one of his streams that
Adventists will say to him that he he
didn't address this or that when the
purpose of that stream is not to address
that. Well, that's the same thing with
my book. It was not meant to address all
those issues. So, it should be treated
fairly like I'm sure he wants his
streams to be treated fairly and rightly
so.
Dr. Lake, here's one of the issues I had
with your book,
and it really had nothing to do with not
being exhaustive on every possible Ellen
White issue,
but you did a lot of the same thing
other SDA scholars are on record doing,
and that's missing the point.
Multiple times in your book, just like
your colleague Michael Campbell does in
his book 1919, which we will be looking
at some next week in my stream with
Steve, you talk of critics of Ellen
White being refuted by demonstrating
that their problems only arise because
of this real rigid view of inspiration.
You use that phrase over and over and
over, and so did Michael uh Campbell.
But no, sir, that's not the root of the
issue. The root issue is God's
effectiveness to communicate. Why is the
Adventist God such a horrible
communicator?
It's just abysmal. It's like I wouldn't
even worship the Adventist God if he
were real.
Such a joke. He's not even a respectable
figure. And I have zero fear and
trepidation saying that because I know
he's not real. He's an idol.
The God of scripture is all knowing and
all powerful. Yet he struggles to
correctly get his message across through
his messenger. Remember this messenger
who her books more than any other book,
more revelation than any other time in
history.
It's not that she just had errors in her
writings. And if you hold to a verbal
inspiration model, there can't be
errors. So therefore, the critics are
invalidated because they don't
understand God inspired the thoughts and
not the words,
which is the argument you try to
present. No, that doesn't change the
facts. It's irrelevant what theory of
inspiration you propose. At the end of
the day, you guys make God a lackluster
communicator at best and a deceiver at
worst.
We didn't even look at the God said to
never change the 1843 chart. Well, then
it changes three times. Well, prison
truth
over and over and over again. She's
wrong. A new light had to be given to
correct the error. That error also
supposedly being from God. The first
one, like the claim, like I said, that
she was shown the Miller chart was never
to be altered and then it was altered
three times. Ellen White claimed all of
it was from God. So, he's all knowing.
He said the chart wasn't supposed to be
changed, but then in the future it was
changed and both of those came from God.
And again, you have to always use the
present truth escape hatch.
And then that's completely refuted.
We've refuted that, too. It's not what
Peter's saying at all. He's saying the
exact opposite of what you guys claim.
This whole teaching predicated upon the
King James translation.
And it's word association fallacy. It's
not even it doesn't make sense in the
context Peter's talking about. I'm
getting ready to go down to the gallows
and get my head chopped off for the Lord
Jesus Christ. Hold fast to the truth
that we have given you and don't budge
off of it. not hold fast to the present
truth that you have, which is really
just some light for right now, but
there's going to be new light in the
future at some point. Yeah.
It's not that your book isn't
exhaustive. It's that the arguments
don't really deal with the root issues.
They may deal with some issues from some
individuals,
but they don't deal with, you know, he
presents it in there like even at the
time. him. It's like, no, it doesn't
even deal with all the issues at the
time because it doesn't even deal with
all of Canr's issues. Makes me wonder
how much of Canrite you've read. How
comprehensively read are you on the
critics?
You guys always say this, the the the
issues have already been dealt with.
It's like I if I had a nickel for every
SDA scholar that has used this excuse,
then you go read the work and it's like
you're not even addressing the issues.
Me and Steve spent like three hours
exactly on that. I'm sure we'll talk
about it again next week, but you are
100% exactly correct. It is not fair to
criticize something or someone for not
being exhaustive when there's only so
much time and you address things with a
particular aim and focus. I get that.
Which is why Dr. Lake, I was really
hoping that you'd actually engage with
some of what you've listened to uh from
this platform, which this is supposed to
be a response to.
Now, I'm really wondering if this is
more about plugging new books that you
guys are going to be putting out and
you'll deal with it there and make me
pay to hear what you're really going to
say about me instead of just engaging
face to face. Am I totally off base in
my analysis, sir?
Come on. So, Dr. Lake, speaking of your
book, one of the core ideas in your book
is that DM Kwright raised almost all the
issues that would be directed against
Ellen White in the future and provided a
model that almost all future critics of
Ellen White would copy, which is why you
called Krite the father of Ellen White
criticisms. However, is it the case that
critics of the life and writings of
Ellen White have followed Ken Wright's
model? Are there criticisms that have
gone beyond Ken Wright's criticisms?
Again, my book was published 14 years
ago and a lot has happened since then.
At the time of this recording, that was
14 years ago, 2010 when the book was
published. And I made this statement
that I've heard others use and
criticize, I I describe Canrite as the
father of Ellen White criticisms uh for
four reasons. Um, first, and this is
quoting from my book, page 60, um, in
the culmination of his work in the life
of Mrs. EG White, he recycled criticisms
of Ellen White's prophetic ministry from
1845 to the late 1880s covered uh, that
I cover uh, in this book. Second, he
conceived new criticisms against her,
such as the plagiarism and epilepsy
charges. I think that's historically
accurate with what Canite did. Third,
Canrite raised almost all the issues
that would be directed against Ellen
White in the future. At his time, there
was a lot of truth to that. And at the
time I wrote the book, as I listened to
all the criticisms, there wasn't much
beyond the framework of what Canite had
done. There was a few things. The charge
that Ellen White was a drunkard. Uh Durk
Anders had already raised that charge,
but since then, of course, new charges
have come. Um ones that Canr never
addressed. And so that's a part that I
would update if I were to to do a new
edition of the book. Uh what's happened
over the last 14 years. I know the
proclamation group has has raised some
new issues that can write didn't raise
the physicality of God issue. I think
Steve Daly in his book the
psychobbiography of Ellen White he has
taken Ellen White criticisms to a level
no one ever has before. his charge that
she was a fraud and one of the greatest
probably the as he puts it the greatest
con artist in history that's quite
extreme and that is a level that Ellen
White criticisms have never gone to
before so clearly Steve Daly has gone
far beyond can write
holy to this woman
yes and Dr. Like, you know what else is
quite an extreme claim?
To claim that you have the mind of God,
the theological God particle, the theory
of everything that was uniquely given to
you all from God through a third grade
educated woman in the 19th century of
America.
What's supposed to be the antidote to
theological division, despite division
being the hallmark stamp of Adventism.
This is a far more extreme claim than
Steve saying that Ellen White was the
biggest con artist in history. That is
peanuts in comparison to what Herbert
Douglas claimed in the December 2000
Ministry magazine. And that is primary
source documentation. Sir,
but I'm glad that you realize that we're
not all DM Canrite parents.
There's something else that I should add
too. A little bit about who DM Canrite
was. DM Canite was converted into
Adventism in 1859.
And for a couple of decades, he became a
well-known, well-beloved preacher.
And while he was an Adventist, Canrite
made some really positive contributions,
especially in the area of tithing. It
was Canright's study that launched the
Adventist church into the major tithing
system that it continues today because
of scripture. That was Canrite. Canite
made some positive contributions, but
Canright in had some issues with
Ellen White and others over the years.
It culminated in his decision to leave
Adventism in 1887. It was a peaceful
exit. Unfortunately, some Adventist
used the word apostasy that was
published in the review that offended
Canrite,
understandably so, and he launched a his
assault on Adventism and continued that
for the last 30 years of his life. So,
he's known as a beloved Adventist
preacher while he was in Adventism, but
also its most well-known critic of that
day uh in in uh once he left Adventism.
But the issue with canite is over the
years we've tended to
demonize canite and there have been
myths about canite that have spread that
are really not true in my own research
and I've researched a lot on canite and
will continue to do so in the future
because I find it to be a very
interesting person and I'm interested in
his person and being fair with who he
was. Obviously I disagree with his
criticisms
but in terms of teller right telling Ken
Wright's story it should be done apart
from any apologetics to his arguments it
should be fair and objective now there
has been a a well-known
narrative of Canrite by Carrie Johnson
who claimed to be a secretary I have
found in my research in uh some of
Kright's material
that Carrie Johnson was not accurate In
fact, I reject the Carrie Johnson
narrative. I think it's unfortunate
and it's not according to the facts that
you find out about Canrite when you read
about his life after he left Adventism.
We need to be fair in telling Canrite's
story. And that hasn't often been the
case. And now our critics are exploiting
the fact that that that has not happened
at
Yeah. I'm glad he recognizes that
Canrite peacefully left the SDAs's and
it would have ended there had the review
and Herald not published their
slanderous hit piece against him. But
Dr. Lake, are you really surprised that
he's using he was called an apostate as
if this is some like anomalous thing? I
mean
apostate
Protestantism.
Thank you John Loccane.
Dr. Lake, this is also peanuts in
comparison to what your prophetist had
to say about others. I mean, seriously,
it's like I hear these things. I'm like,
dude, are you really that surprised?
You're affiliated with this
organization, sir. This stuff hasn't
changed.
We just looked at earlier how she
claimed to be shown from God that those
outside their little band of people on
the path were down in the dark, wicked
world that God had rejected.
You know, that's all those professing
Christians like myself and you know, all
those pagan Roman Catholics and Orthodox
and Assyrian Church of the East and the
Marionite churches and the Syriak
churches and the Baptists and the
Yeah.
All those outside the little flock
that came to their senses realized this
is a sham. Those that never bought into
it. The Methodists that kicked Ellen
White and her fanatic family out and
said, "Get the heck out of here. Stop
proitizing date setting." which the
scriptures explicitly forbid. Oh, they
picked on us for teaching about and
preaching about the second coming. It's
like, man, if I would have been a
Methodist, you know, leader in the
Chestnut Street church where they were,
I would have taken out a scroll of the
Apostles Creed and bopped him over the
head with it. Like, what are you talking
about? This is in the Apostles Creed.
This is like Christianity 101.
Oh, but Ellen rejects the creeds. Oh,
right.
It shouldn't come as a shock that when
you preach damnation on everyone but
your small little group and claim God
showed you this that you're going to
then be heavily scrutinized and struggle
to find larger acceptance. Sir, it's
like modern SDA, you know, apologists
and pastors and leaders, they want to be
accepted now because as time goes on
longer and longer, it's like, oh snap,
we have to try and build partnerships
with the the the folks that we think are
are worse than heathen. We don't want to
tell them that they're worse than
heathen, but in truth, they're worse
than heathen. But we need those
partnerships cuz time's going on. And is
it really imminency 170 years later? And
oh well,
she claimed that we are Babylon. Our
prayers are an abomination to God. Our
churches are filled with evil angels
masquerading as Christians. The
ministers are tools of Satan that
breathe on the people deceptions using
the Bible to keep the people in their
deception leading to false reformations.
We're worse than heathen. And on and on
and on. It's like I mean,
come on, man.
Dr. Lake, I'm glad you're fair and
balanced in your understanding of
canrite though. But where's the public
retraction from the SDA church regarding
I was Canr's secretary?
It was a complete and total fabrication
that bore false witness and tarnished
the Canrite family name.
Where where has any SDA leader denounced
Arthur White's slimy behavior?
You know, it was one thing with Carrie
Johnson, who was a clearly a
pathological liar, who had no supposed
credentials, was a a crackpot that saw a
quick fast track to try and make some
money. But Arthur White, who has been
lauded by the SDA church? Unacceptable,
sir.
I'm not saddling you with that book,
obviously. But why hasn't the SDA church
recognized it and and admitted what you
admitted?
Yes, critics of Adventism are exploiting
this because it was a major cover up
that the Seventh Adventist Church as an
organization was involved in, benefited
from, and hasn't bothered to come clean
on
commandment church, folks. Commandment
keeping church, we're told. Yeah.
Bearing false witness is one of the ten
commandments. I it's like I have to
regularly remind Adventists of this
because again what they really mean when
they mean we're the commandment keeping
church is we go to church on Saturday.
Carrie Johnson and Arthur White claimed
that Canr had a peg leg due to a
Hayfield accident.
No, he didn't. Carrie Johnson was so
stupid that she tried to tell this to
the man's own family. That's how
delusional she was. I imagine doing
that, folks. Imagine coming up with a
total fabrication and then going to a
person's fam family and saying something
as crazy. His his arm was chopped off in
a uh a butchery accident. No, it wasn't.
Yeah, it was.
She had zero credibility. Yet, because
of Arthur White's involvement, the SDA
church supported the book. She claimed
to be his secretary. She wasn't.
She stole the man's diary under the
guise of trying to do his family good
and then slithered it to Walter to
Arthur White to spend years working on
their hit piece. They still have the
diary to this day in the archives.
Yeah.
But as it pertains to Ellen White's
anmatizing of Christians, since it's
going to be claimed, that's all out of
context. There's actually a context in
which what she's saying isn't actually
slanderous regarding Christians. She's
just explaining, you know, what somebody
else said and now you're attributing it
to her. You're taking it out of context.
Something along those lines. Let's
examine a number of these, shall we?
From Spiritual Gifts, volume one.
Not single sentences or statements, sir.
Not omitting page numbers. Go look at
the sources yourself, folks. We always
provide sources. We're not afraid of
people going and checking these things
out. You go fact check this. Study it
out. Quote.
We're going back to the period of time
that we were just in before the early
days.
The early days. I saw the state of the
different churches.
Since the second angel proclamation
or or since the second angel proclaimed
their fall, they have been growing more
and more corrupt. Yet they bear the name
of being Christ's followers.
It is impossible to distinguish them
from the world. Their ministers take
their text from the word but preach
smooth things. The natural heart feels
no objection to this. It's only the
spirit and power of truth and the
salvation of Christ that is hateful to
the carnal heart.
There is nothing in the popular ministry
that stirs the wrath of Satan, makes the
sinner tremble, or applies to the heart
and conscience the fearful realities of
a judgment soon to come. Wicked men are
generally pleased with a form without
true godliness, and they will aid and
support such a religion.
So Ellen was shown in vision
that after the proclamation of the
second angel's message that Babylon had
fallen.
The churches that rejected their
fanaticism were growing more and more
corrupt. Yet they professed to be
Christians. Where have we heard this
before, folks?
Oh, right. the 19 paragraphs that we
read earlier from her almost entire
letter.
No. No. Miles Grant and Linda Berdick
were lying. They just made this up. I
never said had words like that for
anyone, no matter how sinful. Oh, pity
me. Pity me.
This woman, unless she repented, split
hell wide open.
Elsewhere, Ellen wrongfully attributes
this to the rejection of the literal
physical return of Jesus Christ. Like I
was saying earlier, that's her defense
in her life sketches as to why they were
kicked out of the Methodist church. Oh,
it was because we were just trying to
teach the truth about the second coming
that was not actually lost.
No, you were preaching date setting.
Good one. Maybe that's where Adventists
learned this from. It actually makes
sense. Maybe that's why Adventist
scholarship misses the point because so
does Ellen constantly.
It's like, dude, this is such nonsense.
This is a foundational tenant of
Orthodox Christian teaching, folks. It's
in the apostles creed for crying out
loud. They rejected Millerite dates
setting
and re and many rejected imminency, not
the belief in the return of Christ.
Period.
Nevertheless, she said the ministers in
these churches use the Bible to preach
smooth things, but not things that
actually cut to the heart. Only smooth
and flattering things. Nothing in their
preaching makes Satan angry, make
sinners tremble, etc. Yeah. This is in
an era, too, where in the in the other
side of their mouth, they'll talk about
Jonathan Edwards and how his preaching
of sinners in the hands of an angry god
is a fearful way of of getting people to
Christ. You know, it's preaching about
that Roman Catholic eternal conscious
torment teaching you know that the Roman
Catholic Church invented. Little spoiler
alert. I just got done with a discussion
yesterday with Joe Heshmire from
Catholic Answers. Buckle up.
That's all I'm going to say on that. But
we talk about that subject. It was a
great discussion. I'm going to get so
many fiery arrows from evangelicals,
Catholics alike. I love it. I'm not here
to be in any club. I'm not in the
Calvinist club. I'm not in the Reformed
Club. I'm not in the Catholic club. I
associate and have friends all across
the board. That's not the purpose of
what we were doing. But nevertheless,
she continues,
said the angel, nothing less than the
whole armor of righteousness can
overcome and retain the victory over the
powers of darkness. Satan has taken full
possession of the churches as a body.
The sayings and doings of men are dwelt
upon instead of the plain cutting truths
of the word of God, said the angel. The
friendship and the spirit of the world
are at emity with God. When truth in its
simplicity and strength, as it is in
Jesus, is brought to bear against the
spirit of the world, it awakens the
spirit of persecution at once. Ah, yeah.
Cuz their their 1844 message was just a
plain thus sayeth the Lord, right?
And when people had it brought up to
him, persecution came for the little
flock. Oh, they were persecuted because
people critiqued their theology.
Meanwhile, she's literally preaching
damnations and anathemas. Charles Fitch
is claiming, "You reject
premillennialism. Damnation on you."
Just so laughable. Many, very many who
profess to be Christians have not known
God. The character of the natural heart
has not been changed, and the carnal
mind remains at eminity with God. They
are Satan's own faithful servants.
Notwithstanding, they have assumed
another name. Close quote.
So, Satan's taken full possession of
these churches as a body.
This was shown to her by the angel sent
from God supposedly. These churches are
filled with false converts. Their
characters aren't changed. Their minds
are still carnal. They're still at en
enmity with God. These people are
faithful servants of Satan. yada yada.
Yeah. News flash, folks. You don't need
an extra biblical revelation from a
woman in in the 19th century to tell you
there's false converts in churches.
Hello.
No one needs an extra biblical prophet
to know that not every person who
professes to be a Christian isn't. The
Bible itself says this. But she isn't
only saying that despite what some SDA
apologists might want you to think
because she continues in the next
paragraph.
I saw that since Jesus had left the holy
place of the heavenly sanctuary and had
entered within the second veil, the
churches were left as were the Jews. Ah,
this is perfectly in line, Dr. White or
or not Dr. White, sorry, uh, Dr. Lake,
with what we read earlier.
The churches were left, as were the
Jews, and they had been filling up with
every unclean and hateful bird. I saw
great iniquity and vileeness in the
churches, yet they profess to be
Christians. Their profession, their
prayers, and their exhortations are an
abomination in the sight of God. Close
quote.
Is that a single sentence, sir?
Is that a single quote out of context?
Just a damn near three paragraphs.
but specifically the churches of Ellen
White's day that rejected their 1844
claims regarding the move of Jesus from
the holy place to the most holy. Like we
just saw earlier,
they were left like the Jews of Jesus's
day in darkness.
These churches were filling up with
people who professed to be Christians.
Remember these false reformations?
They weren't really being converted
because they were rejecting the 1844
message.
But their prayers and their professions
and exhortations are an abomination in
the sight of God for rejecting 1844.
Well, sir, we still reject it to this
day, which would mean apparently this
still applies.
It's like, well, was this some timebased
claim where we were only an abomination
in the sight of God for a season, but
now that time has rolled on and new
present truth has been given, well, it's
no longer valid. Satan no longer
controls our churches.
He just gave them up. He just conceded.
He's not breathing on us anymore.
Oh man. She's like,
"What, bro? What are you talking about,
man?"
Oh, man. Some of these defenses, folks,
I'm telling you, it's like I got to
commend you for at least trying because,
you know, reading that you're like,
"Well, shoot.
like, "Yeah, dang. She's really ripping
him a new one."
And they know it's like if you were to
bring this up to doctor, like I I I
know. He'd be like, "Well, no, he thinks
I'm a Christian. I've talked with him. I
don't think he is because he affirms
official SDA teaching." And I've told
him that. I don't think he's a bad
person. I don't think he's a mean guy,
but I don't think he understands the the
the the truth of the gospel. I don't
think he understands the true God. I
don't think he knows the true Christ.
But it's like when there's statements
like this, sir.
Yeah. You're not going to find
acceptance with Christians. Sorry. And
early on, your movement knew who you
guys were. It's not this modern-day
hodgepodge of kumbaya around the fire.
Oh, it's a big tent. You know, we got
all sorts of people. You know, you don't
you don't have to believe the Sabbath.
You don't have to believe the
investigative judgment. It's just, oh,
you know, come on in. Yeah. No. Yeah.
Give me a break.
I've heard Dr. Lakes's responses to
stuff like this, and I'm sorry, it is
just not cutting it. Claiming that this
was some timebound thing that only
applied back then, it's not applicable
to now just creates more problems and
issues for them.
He does the same thing with a number of
her health reform claims and some other
ones in the modern day. And even he
knows these are ridiculous, which is why
he says this stuff about tea and
condiments. I asked him about this in
class. I'm like, "Dude, do you seriously
think that eating pickles is a sin?" He
said, "Well, you have to understand."
No, doctor. Like, come on. Come on.
Don't try and defend this nonsense. Give
it up, sir. Come on. Come join the
Christian church and leave this behind.
I understand it's a lot harder for
someone like him where his whole
livelihood, his reputation, all of that
is tied to Adventism, but I'm sorry,
sir. Jesus calls you to be
uncomfortable.
Jesus calls you to be uncomfortable. And
Jesus is more important than Adventism.
He is. He's worth it.
But nevertheless, this does not change
the fact that she still said God showed
her this regarding Christians. The same
woman that assured us in 1873. She never
had harsh words like that for anyone, no
matter how sinful they were.
I never had a vision. You've never read
from my pen. Yeah. Bologoney.
Bologoney.
Must be nice to have the present truth
magic wand where literally anything
that's presented can just be objected by
saying prison truth. Ding.
Yeah,
but this is why I'm always left
wondering how SDAs can try and play the
victim complex card and wonder why
Christians are hesitant to accept
Adventism as part of the body of Christ.
Uh because you're definitionally an
accuser of the brethren.
Your prophetist claimed all sorts of
stuff like this. It's what you guys
teach that we are apostate
Protestantism.
Thank you, John Lomang. And not true
worshippers of God because we don't have
the light that you guys do. Yet at the
same time, Adventists want to be seen as
no different than the apostates that
their entire identity is predicated upon
distinguishing themselves from.
You only get a pass if you're ignorant
of the SDA message because then you're
saved in ignorance.
But people like myself, Steve Dailyaly,
Colleen Tinker, EJ Lston, Dale Ratzife,
no. Your guys's theology says that we
are damned because we have rejected the
greatest light that God has given in all
of human history.
Because remember, Ellen White said there
was never a time when God instructed his
people more earnestly than he instructs
them now concerning his will and the
course that he would have them pursue.
Again, another statement we've looked at
in total before and regularly site for
him. This is a manuscript, Dr. Lake,
that is three paragraphs long.
Quote, "The greatest prejudice of the
Jewish nation of priests and rulers was
stirred up against Christ because the
people preferred to listen to Jesus
rather than to them. The very same
feelings of prejudice will be manifest
in the priests and rulers of this time.
We can do nothing that would close up
the way before us in this country like
taking a position of superiority and
putting before the people that we
consider them heathen. In truth, they're
worse than heathen. But this were not to
tell them." The clergy consider
themselves as teachers, highly
religious, and their churches send out
missionaries to the work of converting
the savages. But to have the implication
that a similar work must be done for
them, they would consider the worst kind
of insult. Close quote.
Many in the audience are going to be
able to tell you the context of this
letter, Dr. Lake, because we've gone
over it, I don't even know how many
times at this point. This is from
correspondence that she had with an
Adventist missionary in England. The SDA
movement had virtually zero presence
there and he was wondering how to go
about getting that started and spreading
the SDA message. In her response to him,
which is what this is from, Ellen
utilizes her favorite analogy like we
just saw of Jesus and the Jews and says,
"The religious leaders of their day will
be like the Jews of Jesus's day." Since
that is the case, they could do nothing
that would close up the way before them
like taking a position of superiority by
telling them that they're worse than
heathen. The ministers,
in truth, they're worse than heathen.
But they're not to tell them this
because the clergy, like the Jews of
Jesus's day, consider themselves learned
and they send out their own
missionaries. So for excuse me so for
them to be told that a similar work of
conversion must be done for them by this
Adventist missionary they would find a
great insult.
Nothing taken out of context. Go read
the letter folks. It's not even that
long. Manuscript releases volume 17.
Over and over and over again. This woman
was anatizing the true body of Christ,
distinguishing the SDA movement as
entirely separate from that. And we're
supposedly rampant with theological
confusion and division, and Adventism is
supposed to be immune from all that. And
on and on and on.
Yet you guys want to be accepted amongst
the body of Christ, but only so you can
begin proitizing us like the the
heathens that we are. Right?
We're almost entirely done with the
response and we have yet to hear a
single objection I've raised
meaningfully engaged not just regarding
Ellen White but period
Steve Daly's latest book the the fraud
of of um the white estate fraud. Um, and
there are some things in that book that
uh, you know, that that I would agree
with, but I believe it's one-sided and I
believe there's another that that the
whole story needs to be told. And I know
that the white estate is is working on
researching that and telling the full
story. Of course, as far as he is
concerned, the white estate is
untrustworthy. But I believe that when
that story is documented with careful
research, it will be a balanced
presentation of the whole thing. But
nevertheless, a lot of us realize that
the Carrie Johnson narrative is false
and it is most unfortunate and that is
has not been fair to Canr. And I believe
that uh the other biography of Canrite
by Norman Dowy who was not a Seventh Day
Adventist was more favorable was against
Adventist and favorable towards Canrite.
Carrie Johnson of course was was
favorable towards Adventism and against
Canright. Both of them tend to take it
to the extreme. Although I will
acknowledge I think that the the uh
biography of Canrite by Norman Dowy is
more is is is more objective and is a
better uh biography overall. But I
believe that the real canrite lies
somewhere in the middle of those two
because both of them are parochial in
their presentations and use testimonial
evidence and and there's there's a bias
working on both sides. Again, this is
not to excuse I think some of the things
that happened with Carrie Johnson which
are most unfortunate but still that that
happens and I believe the real canrite
is somewhere in the middle and his story
needs to be told. It's a part of our
story. I think we have a right to tell
it but we've got to do it in a fair and
objective way apart from Ken Wright's
arguments. So uh that's I think those
are some of the issues with regard to
Ken right
see Dr. Like there was a perfect
example.
Dowy's book is not a the same thing as
Steve's book.
Steve talked about this when he was on
here and very clearly Christopher is
asking questions that you guys clearly
listen to that stream because all the
questions that you're asking are dancing
around stuff that was said in that
stream.
But Dowy's book was not a
psychobiography of Ellen White.
It was a totally different thesis.
Makes me wonder if you've read it
comprehensively, sir.
But yes, the white estate is not
trustworthy.
We just went over this and you yourself
mentioned it. I was Canr secretary. The
White Estate was heavily involved in
that knowing it was a total fabrication
carefully crafted together by Carrie
Johnson and Arthur White. But
furthermore,
we've already seen this circus act 500
times, folks.
It's like, been there, done that, got
the t-shirt.
Are you really trying to tell us that
the White Estate is going to do what
you're saying Steve didn't?
And that's not have any sort of bias,
but present a a totally unbiased
response to Steve.
He should get into standup, sir.
like this is a joke.
Yeah, the the white estate does not have
a a good track record.
They have been caught in numerous
falsehoods
and I myself am working on one that can
be added to the pile. I'm not going to
disclose exactly what it is until it's
published. But no, their track record is
not good, sir. And this is going to be
embarrassing for them because whoever is
doing the the Well, I'm not going to get
into it because I don't want to give any
anything away. you guys will see
getting caught with their tail between
their legs. Steve's book presents more
problems than just the Carrie Johnson
issue as well. It presents issues
regarding the white estate and their
credibility, the SDA church's laundry
list of cover-ups and not coming clean
on certain issues, which is why they
keep piling up and eventually something
stacks so high it falls and spills over
onto everyone else. And that's what's
happening. It's caught up with this
organization. You can't just keep lying
and lying and lying and lying and lying
and lying
thinking it's not going to catch up with
you.
Shoot. If Ellen White was so apparently
was a involved in Back to the Future,
she just constantly knew what the future
was going to hold. She just didn't have
any clue that the internet was going to
come along. You'd think that, man, she
she just of all the things she could
have known about the future, you know,
because the almighty God was speaking
through her more than he's ever spoke in
in all of human history. You'd think
that he would have mentioned something
to her about this thing called the
internet.
This movement has been given so many
opportunities in the past to come clean.
Dez Ford, Walter Ray, Dale Ratzlaf, etc.
And every single time the messenger is
attacked and the SDA organization tries
silencing people and doing PR to
preserve an image that they want people
to have about the commandmentkeeping
church.
No, that's why this platform takes the
approach that we do. Those days are
over. You had your chance. You had your
chance.
But again, I want to say it is
commendable that Dr. Lake recognizes the
issues regarding not representing
canrite fairly. And I think a lot of
Adventists could learn from that.
But the SDA church has yet to
demonstrate themsel uh uh yet to to
demonstrate themselves what Dr. Lake is
seeking for critics of Adventism to do.
Present a balanced perspective.
Just watch my discussion with Steve Daly
and Alberto Tim's responses to Steve.
Okay. To continue examining Ken Wright's
criticisms, you state in your book Ellen
White Under Fire on page 59 that DM Ken
Wright missed the revival after the 1888
meetings and never mentioned it in his
criticism of 7th Day Adventism. What
would you say, Dr. Lake, is the
significance of the 1888 meetings and
their impact on the 7th Day Adventist
Christian faith today? Yes. And uh I I'm
just noticing now that critics are
attemp attempting to downplay 1888
because it was a great revival.
Adventists have set it forth as a
revival of righteousness by faith and so
forth. And they're tending to downplay
it. But that is one of the the the the
areas that has a lot of research in
Adventist history. George Knight,
prolific Adventist historian, has
written a lot in that area. Others have
have written material. I've read
doctrinal dissertations about that as
well. And it's documented that that 1888
it there was a great revival as a result
of that within Adventism. You can read
that in the pages of the Review and
Herald uh in the in the early 1890s.
Jones and Wagner, two of the major
contenders. And by the way, their
biographies have been written. So
there's a lot of research. George Knight
wrote the at Jones V. Woody Wooden wrote
the EJ Wagner. So there's a lot of
research that has been done about this
issue and Ellen White uh agreed with the
core of what Jones and Wagner said
during the 1888 meetings. Not everything
that they taught but but the core of
what they said about salvation and he
was determined to get that message out
to the church. And they did so and it
brought forth a revival. You can see
that in the general conferences during
the 1890s. You can see that in the in
the Harbor Springs
uh uh convention on education where they
changed the course of Adventist
education and determined to make it
teach the whole Bible with Christ at the
center more gospel- centered Bible
teaching that was a part of the fallout
from the 1888 meetings. The positive
fallout from it. It's documented of the
impact, the positive impact of 1888 that
would continue through the rest of the
century. Although it's important to
point out that there was a shift, there
was a change uh in the trajectory of
things as you get into the n uh the 20th
century. Michael Campbell has documented
in his books uh on the 1919 Bible
conference and the 1922 general
conference session the unfortunate
trajectory that things went. the message
of salvation got lost sight of and and a
trajectory of legalism
began and and made its way into the 20th
century and and that trajectory
continued throughout the 20th century.
George Knight has documented this in his
book Ellen White's afterlife about the
way Ellen White was used and abused
during that time. She literally was
exalted in such a way that that Sister
White walked three feet off the ground.
And uh that is a most insightful book
that updates all the research and
experience on Ellen White after her
death. Appropriate title, Ellen White's
afterlife. He also wrote in time events
in the last generation, the explosive
1950s, where you have this idea of the
last generation attempting to come to
become perfect. And that set in motion a
series of events and ideas that that
continue this trajectory of legalism
throughout the 20th century. And so by
the time you get to the 1970s and you
have the the historical critical
research done on Ellen White, it was the
church was not expecting that. By the
time you get to the 1980s, Walter Ray's
release of his book, The White Lie, the
church was not ready for that. the way
they had viewed Ellen White. They had
forgotten that the plagiarism charge had
already been addressed. Canrite had
raised it and it had been addressed in
the early decades of the the century,
but it was forgotten and it was like a
bombshell that exploded and the church
was caught off guard and it was a really
challenging time. But again, that caused
us to do more research into that topic.
Yeah, Dr. Blake, I have Michael
Campbell's 1919 book. I've been back in
it recently, like I said, in preparation
for discussion with Dr. Steve Dailyaly
next week on that exact topic. I'm aware
of all of this, sir.
This is what I'm saying. They clearly
are responding because Steve and I
talked about this the last time he was
on. So, they're trying to tap dance
around the claims, which one of them
that I made, this is the closest we've
gotten now to actually engaging. So,
thank you, Dr. Lake.
But no, there wasn't this major shift in
1888 as we're gonna as we're going to
see. I'm not trying to say I know
everything, but I'm simply putting it
out there to say I've read your guys'
materials, a lot of them, thousands of
pages.
Like we saw in the last part, you said,
"I need to read Contours of
Adventistology." I cited from it during
the stream and have the book. I have
your book. I have George Knight's books.
I have a rather extensive SDA library.
But this isn't really a response to this
platform, folks. This is more prowling
off of SDA Scholastic Works to make it
appear like there's this whole world out
there of information that needs to be
tapped into that silences the critics of
Adventism.
He said, "Critics are starting to try
and downplay 1888." Dr. Lake, I can't
speak for everyone, but I can speak for
myself.
My criticisms of 1888 are not something
I've only raised recently.
Once again, we are taken back to part
one, which is the fountain head from
where all these problems spring. You
guys use phrases like righteousness by
faith, justification by faith, the
gospel,
but that's in the context of the great
controversy paradigm
which Herb Douglas has already informed
us was uniquely given to you guys. You
didn't discover it. It's not coming from
the scriptures. It's something you all
bring to the biblical text and operate
from that standpoint
assuming that it's true and then you
interpret everything in light of that.
I mean, I don't know anyone that
criticizes 1888 by saying there was no
revival within Adventism that took
place.
I I mean maybe there are people out
there that are saying this, but that's
not the criticism that I've levied. It's
not what I've heard other people bring
up. The issue is how you you guys define
things.
This is the standard play by SDA, modern
SDA scholarship to appeal to 1888 to try
and say Adventism is this radically
different thing post all that happening.
Yeah, we got all the problems ironed out
in 1888. K Wright's criticisms were all
invalid because, well, he didn't
understand post188
Adventism. But no, as we've looked at
numerous times, including the past two
parts, this is not true. Changes did
indeed happen in 1888 and after. But as
I've described it, that's just a
changing of window dressing. That's not
at the foundation. At the end of the
day, you're still selling the great
controversy worldview.
In fact, we're talking about fundamental
belief number 18, which is a perfect
example of this. The SDA church updated
the wording of the belief in 2017, I
believe it was, but it is fundamentally
no different than it was before. Look at
what the belief used to say.
Quote, "One of the gifts of the Holy
Spirit is prophecy. This gift is an
identifying mark of the remnant church
and was manifested in the ministry of
LG. fight as the Lord's messenger. Her
writings are a continuing and
authoritative source of truth which
provides for the church comfort,
guidance, instruction, and correction.
They also make clear that the Bible is
the standard by which all teaching and
experience must be tested. Close quote.
They changed a continuing and
authoritative source of truth to her
writings speak with prophetic authority.
But they didn't actually change their
belief around.
You really think they don't still
believe that she's a continuing and
authoritative source of truth? No. They
changed the wording to make it more
innocuous and plausibly deniable.
This is what SDA modern scholarship does
regarding Adventist theology. It doesn't
fundamentally change. They just change
the window dressing by wording things
differently, trying to make it sound new
when it's the same old product. It's the
great controversy worldview in a
different packaging. He mentioned at uh
uh uh uh Alonzo Jones and and and Ellott
Wagner, EJ Wagner. Yeah. The Wag Wagner
was a christoologgical heretic as we've
looked at before. A person who's a
christoologgical heretic cannot possibly
understand the true gospel because Paul
tells us in Galatians 1:12 that the true
gospel comes from the true Christ. If
you have the wrong Christ, you're going
to have the wrong gospel. But that issue
aside, let's examine Wagner's explaining
of righteousness by faith, shall we?
This is supposed to be what's the
drastic upgrade for for for pre-18 or or
from from pre-188 Adventism. Folks,
notice
after citing Isaiah 516-7,
he writes,
"What do we learn from this? that they
who know the righteousness of God are
those in whose heart is his law. And
therefore that the law of God is the
righteousness of God.
The law of God is the righteousness of
God. This may be proved again as
follows. All unrighteousness is sin. 1
John 5:7. Whoever committh sin
transgresseth also the law. For sin is
the transgression of the law. 1 John
3:4, sin is the transgression of the
law, and it is also unrighteousness.
Therefore, sin and unrighteousness are
identical.
But if unrighteousness is transgression
of the law, righteousness must be
obedience to the law.
Or to put the proposition into
mathematical form,
unrighteousness equals sin. 1 John 5:17,
transgression of the law equals sin. 1
John 3:4. Therefore, according to the
axiom that two things that are equal to
the same thing as equal to each other,
we have unrighteousness equals
transgression of the law, which is a
negative equation. The same thing stated
in positive terms would be righteousness
equals obedience to the law.
Now what law is it obedience to which is
righteousness and disobedience to which
is sin? It is that law which says thou
shalt not covet. For the apostle Paul
tells us that the law uh uh that this
law convinced him of sin. Romans 7:7,
"The law of ten commandments then is the
measure of the righteousness of God."
Close quote. What did he say is the
measure of the righteousness of God?
The law, the ten commandments. Okay.
So according to Wagner, the champion of
the 1888 righteousness by faith message,
the righteousness of God is keeping the
ten commandments. That's how a person
can have the righteousness of God.
As I've pointed out many times before,
without Jesus's assistance, it wouldn't
be possible to do it. It's not full-on
palagianism.
It's not, oh, man just can pull himself
up by his bootstraps without any sort of
No, no, no. It's semipolagian. Jesus
opened the door like we're going to look
at in a little bit. But his death made
it possible for you to now come to him
and receive power to keep the law. And
in doing so, Christ imparts his
righteous merits to you in small spurts
in accordance with your cooperation,
which gradually makes you more and more
righteous ontologically.
It's not just well, we'll get into that
in a moment, but this will eventually
lead you to a point where the law is
fulfilled within you and then you have a
righteousness that mirrors Jesus's. It's
not your righteousness in the true
sense. It's Jesus's because he gradually
was imparting it to you over time to a
point where you got to keeping the law
perfectly.
You know, he mentions last generation
theology and and kind of poo poos on
that. Yeah.
Okay.
It was his righteous merits imparted to
you, not your own. They're going to tell
you. This then fulfills the requirements
of the law within you, as well as
silences Satan's accusations in the
great controversy and vindicates God's
character. And as we saw in part two,
getting to this totally sinless
condition is necessary in order to be
saved.
God can only save you if that's the
case. Otherwise, Satan's charge will
stand.
This idea that they try to downplay this
is because their conscience probably
sears like a hot iron and they recognize
that they still fall short despite
trying your best which is what most SDAs
try to say the standard is. But it would
have done EJ Wagner good to read oh I
don't know uh the whole book of Romans
not this buffet style um approach that
they like to use but exoggetically
because his syllogism breaks down when
one realizes you can't just read all
over the Bible and port in definitions
as though some words and phrases don't
have a semantic range.
I I mean he didn't even take the
literary genre into consideration. He
appeals to the poetry in the psalter,
the epistle of first John and the
epistle to the Romans. And in doing so,
he engaged in the fallacy of
illegitimate totality transfer. He
didn't work through the author's use of
the words in the direct setting that
they were being used and derive his
conclusion off of that because notice
what Romans 3:21 through31 says.
But now the righteousness of God has
been manifested
apart from the law.
Although the law and the prophets bear
witness to it, the righteousness of God
through faith in Jesus Christ for all
who believe. For there's no distinction,
for all have sinned and fall short of
the glory of God, and are justified by
his grace as a gift, not a reward,
through the redemption that is in Christ
Jesus, whom God put forward as a
propitiation by his blood to be received
by faith. This was to show God's
righteousness
because in his divine forbearance, he
had passed over former sins. It was to
show his righteousness at the present
time so that he might be just and the
justifier of the one who has faith in
Jesus. Then what becomes of our
boasting? It is excluded by what kind of
law?
By a law of works?
No, but by the law of faith.
For we hold that one is justified by
faith apart from works of the law.
Or is God the God of Jews only? Is he
not the God of Gentiles also? Yes, of
Gentiles also, since God is one. Who
will justify the circumcised by faith
and the uncircumcised through faith? Do
we then overthrow the law by this faith?
By no means. On the contrary, we uphold
the law and thus the reading of God's
holy word.
Ah, so verse 21 totally foils Wagner's
syllogism.
He said, "Obedience to the law is the
righteousness of God." Yet Paul tells us
that the righteousness of God has been
manifested apart from the law.
The law and the prophets pointed to it,
meaning the Old Testament, they
foreshadowed what Paul is putting forth
here. This concept of justification by
faith.
And what does Paul directly say? This
righteousness of God is the
righteousness that comes through faith
in Christ Jesus. Which is why Paul could
then say in verse 28 that he maintained
that man is justified apart from works
of the law. But according to Wagner,
justification can't be by faith apart
from works of the law. Because in their
system, it's faith that empowers you to
keep the law and receive Christ's merits
gradually over time
imparted to you in accordance with your
keeping of the law.
But no, the righteousness of God that
the believer receives is entirely
distinct and separate apart from the
law.
And this is why I'm constantly telling
you folks, this movement does not
understand the law gospel distinction.
Once again, we see a mixing of law and
gospel that happens within Adventist
theology. But then Paul anticipating his
Jewish convert,
which is who this audience was, Jewish
convert Christians, to think this
somehow contradicts the law and the
prophets, the idea of being justified
apart from the law. He says that this
doesn't overthrow the law, but rather
upholds it.
Adventists love to cite verse 31.
Oh, just one second here.
Adventists love to cite verse 31
but miss what is actually being said.
Paul is saying that what he just laid
out
does not contradict the law and the
prophets.
That's what he means.
That did did what I just put out here
contradict what the Old Testament says?
No. Rather, it upholds that Adventists
read this and they'll proof text verse
31 to try and make terrible arguments
for the Ten Commandments.
not even looking at the flow of what
what Paul is getting at because then he
this is why he immediately transfers
into the next chapter to talk about
Abraham and David Old Testament examples
who he points to as an example of them
being justified the same way even prior
to the incarnation.
It's the same way any person is seen as
righteous before God. And what does Paul
say in Romans 4? Abraham
believed God and it was credited to him
as righteousness. That's apart from the
law.
Not Abraham believed God, obeyed, and
then because he obeyed, God gradually
imparted to him his own righteous merits
to Abraham in accordance with his
obedience to the law. No, Abraham obeyed
because he was righteous in God's sight.
When a person truly believes and trusts
God, that's just the natural outflow.
But that walking out in obedience does
not involve having righteous merits
gradually imparted to you. The point
being, no, the righteousness of God is
not obedience to the ten commandments.
The righteousness of God is Jesus Christ
himself, who by turning to him in faith
and repentance, a person can be seen as
fully righteous before God in him, union
with Christ being the central thing. But
furthermore, sin is not just an action
like a verb. It is also a condition, a
noun. Wagner's proposition defines sin
exclusively as a verb, which misses the
whole point of what Paul then goes on to
say in Romans 5, specifically 12-14,
that sin came into the world through
Adam prior to the law,
which indicates sin as a noun, is not
only when one does something sinful. The
very fact that sin was in the world
before the law was given shows that sin
is a condition that came to all of
Adam's descendants because he sinned.
So all of that to say, Dr. Lake, this
problem was not extinguished in 1888,
sir. But also notice Galatians 3 10-14,
for all who rely on works of the law are
under a curse. For it is written, cursed
be everyone who does not abide by all
things written in the book of the law
and do them. Now it is evident that no
one is justified before God by the law.
For the righteous shall live by faith.
But the law is not of faith.
Rather, the one who does them who does
them shall live by them. Christ redeemed
us from the curse of the law by becoming
a curse for us. For it is written,
cursed is everyone who h who is hanged
on a tree. So that in Christ Jesus, the
blessing of Abraham might come to the
Gentiles so that we might receive the
promised spirit through faith. Ah
once again we plainly see the law gospel
distinction. Paul says anyone who's
seeking to be justified by any sort of
lawkeeping is under a curse because
cursed is anyone who doesn't do all of
the things written in the book of the
law. And yes, despite the SDA church's
protestations, the book of the law
contained all of the law. Ten
commandments were included twice. It was
the entire pentatuk. We have a video on
this. It just it's the Old Testament is
replete with this.
The book of the law was the entire
penetuk which contained the ten
commandments in both old and new or or
rather well it's talked about in the new
testament but it it included the ten
commandments that are found both in the
first giving in Exodus and the second
giving in Deuteronomy.
For those that do not know the SDA
church seeks to uphold the position that
the law in focus here is only Jewish
ordinances.
So Paul isn't saying that relying on
moral works for justification is wrong,
but relying on ceremonies like
circumcision. Now they are not alone in
this, but that issue aside, Paul plainly
says that no one is justified before God
by the law. The righteous shall live by
faith, totally consistent with what we
just read in Romans 3. But according to
Wagner and the 1888 push, righteousness
is defined as obedience to the law, and
in doing so, you gradually receive the
imparted righteous merits of God. But
no, that's not what Paul taught. Not
here or in Romans. He says the law is
not a faith. And the curse of the law
that Jesus saved us from is not only
ceremonial cursings.
He plainly said, "Cursed is everyone who
does not everything contained in the
book of the law."
And that book included all of the law.
Jesus redeemed us from the curse of it
all, not just ceremonial laws.
You weren't cursed for only violating
the ceremonial commands, but not the
moral ones. you were under curse for
violation of any of it. Period.
But this is also why I'm constantly
pointing out that the SDA teaching
misplaces obedience.
They put the cart before the horse as
Wagner so plainly told us. Righteousness
to an Adventist means obedience to the
law when no obedience to God period, not
just the Ten Commandments, is the fruit
of already possessing the righteousness
of God apart from the law.
They they do not understand the law
gospel distinction, folks. I'm telling
you, we're going to keep hammering this.
I can't tell you how many SDAs or former
SDAs now, praise God, have been
redpilled on this because once it
clicks, it's over. It's another area,
Dr. Lake, you guys are going to need to
refute the law gospel distinction.
And while you're at it, you will
demonstrate for us another catch22 that
you guys are in because you claim to be
heirs of the reformation and the law
gospel distinction is literally central
to all the the reformation across the
board. German lu, you know, Lutheran,
Anglicans, Presbyterians.
But it's why Paul could go on to say in
Romans 5:1, "Therefore, having been
justified by faith, we have peace with
God." And in Romans 8:1, there is
therefore now no condemnation for those
who are in Christ. Again, that term of
union with Jesus.
That's not to be confused with the SDA
church, SJ SDA church's teaching of
abiding in Christ.
The law cannot condemn me because it
would have to be able to condemn Jesus.
I am in him. One enters into him by
faith. Adventism does not teach this.
And in fact, their scholars tend to b
and scoff at this with their favorite
screed of Calvinism when it's actually
just classical Protestant belief.
Lutheran, Anglicans, and the reformed
disagreed on some of the inner mechanics
on this, such as Lutheran, for example,
that believe you can forfeit your
benefits in Christ, but they don't
believe that your obedience maintains
that.
But foundationally, we're all united.
So, no, Dr. like, "I'm sorry. You You
guys didn't get things cleaned up in
1888.
Was there a change in splits that
happened because something did happen?"
Of course. I I know no one that denies
this, but you're doing that thing again
where you're not actually getting into
the uh finer details, but you're just
using vague Christianes that doesn't
mean much when you define everything
through the great controversy theme. He
mentioned Ellen White agreeing with
Jones and Wagner fundamentally. Yes. And
Dr. lake. We looked at that in detail in
part two. We have looked at it
systematically numerous times here. But
let's look at this once again. Okay.
First,
notice what Ellen White says Christ
accomplished.
Quote, "Through Christ, a door of hope
was opened that man, notwithstanding his
great sin, should not be under the
absolute control of Satan.
faith in the merits of the son of God
would so elevate man that he could
resist the devices of Satan.
Probation would be granted him in which
through a life of repentance and faith
in the atonement of the son of God
investigative judgment he might be
redeemed from his transgression of the
father's law and thus be elevated to a
position where his efforts to keep the
law could be accepted.
Close quote. We have looked at this
numerous times and I've utilized this
language to describe the Adventist
system. Christ opened a door making
salvation a possibility. Without him, it
wouldn't be possible. It's all by grace
through faith,
which is what they mean when they're
using all of grace or the various
iterations of that. You come to the
Adventist Jesus by faith and his merits
elevate you to a position to now be able
to resist Satan. Elsewhere, we've looked
at how she said it empowers you to not
uh uh empowers you now to be able to
keep the law. You are granted a second
second probation, another phrase that
she regularly used. And through a life
of repentance and faith in the
atonement, which we saw in part two,
according to contours, the book Dr. Lake
told us we need to engage with that by
the word atonement, they mean the
investigative judgment.
You can be redeemed from having broken
God's law and be elevated to a position
where your efforts to keep the law can
now be accepted.
Notice what she says regarding
sanctification in their system,
which is perfectly in line with what I
just said. quote, "When it is in the
heart to obey God, when efforts are put
forth to this end, Jesus accepts this
disposition and effort as man's best
service and he makes up for the the
deficiency with his own divine merit."
Close quote. So when a person desires to
obey God and puts their best effort
forth, Jesus accepts that and then he
makes up for where man falls short by
imparting to them his divine merits.
Which is precisely why she also said
this.
Will man take hold of divine power and
with determination and perseverance
resist Satan as Christ has given him
example in his conflict with the foe in
the wilderness of temptation? God cannot
save man against his will from the power
of Satan's artififices.
Man must work with his human power aided
by the divine power of Christ to resist
and to conquer at any cost to himself.
In short, man must overcome as Christ
overcame.
And then through the victory that is his
privilege to gain by the all powerful
name of Jesus, he may become an heir of
God and joint heir with Jesus Christ.
This could not be the case if Christ
alone did all the overcoming.
Man must do his part. He must be victor
on his own account through the strength
and grace that Christ gives him. Man
must be a co-worker with Christ in the
labor of overcoming and then he will be
partaker with Christ in his glory. Close
quote.
Jesus empowers you to co-labor alongside
him. You try your best and Jesus makes
up the difference on the gradual path to
sinless perfectionism. Only if you
overcome as Jesus overcame will you
inherit eternal life and share with
Christ in his glory. Speaking about the
purpose of the law, she wrote,
"God has given man a complete rule of
life in his law. Obeyed, he shall live
by it through the merits of Christ.
Transgressed, it has the power to
condemn. The law sends men to Christ and
Christ points them back to the law."
close quote. The law points a person to
Jesus, showing them their need of a
savior, and by coming to him, he
empowers them to do what the law enjoys.
Obeyed, one will live through Christ's
merits. Transgressed, it will condemn
you. So, ignore what Paul says in Romans
8 that those who are in Christ can't be
condemned by anything. No, no, no. She
tells you that the law can still condemn
you on the path of gradually becoming
sinlessly perfect.
In Desire of Ages, speaking on the same
subject,
the law requires righteousness, a
righteous life, a perfect character, and
this man has not to give. He cannot meet
the claims of God's holy law.
But Christ coming to the earth as man,
lived a holy life and developed a
perfect character. These he offers as a
free gift to all who will receive them.
His life stands for the life of men.
Thus they have remission of sins that
are passed
through the forbearance of God. More
than this, Christ imbuss men with the
attributes of God. He builds up the
human character after the similitude of
the divine character, a godly fabric of
spiritual strength and beauty. Thus, the
very righteousness of the law is
fulfilled in the believer in Christ. God
can be just and the justifier of him
which believeth in Jesus. Romans 3:6.
Close quote. So when you come to Christ
in this system, you're empowered to now
begin keeping the law. You have the
remission of sins that are only passed.
Christ then begins imbuing you with his
righteous merits like we saw in selected
messages. And he builds up your
character after his because he developed
a perfect character. The law is then
fulfilled in the individual by means of
having enough of Jesus's righteous
merits imparted to you.
And this is supposed to be supported by
Romans 3:6. Tell me you aren't following
Paul's apologetic presentation without
telling us you're not following Paul's
presentation. That is not at all what
God
that's not at all what God being the
just and the justifier is saying. Paul
is explaining that God is not unjust.
And this was demonstrated in the fact
that he didn't let sin slide but
punished it in the person of Christ.
That's what the sins of of forbearance
and overlooking is is is actually
referring to. Again, Adventists butcher
this. They think, well, people didn't
have even really have a knowledge of sin
prior to. No, that's not what's being
said there. It's that God did not wink
at all the sin that was taking place
back then, but actually punished it as
well as all the other sins in the person
of Christ.
He didn't let it slide. He's just.
And because he did that and punished
sin,
that's why he can also be uh the
justifier in justifying people strictly
on the basis of faith in Jesus Christ
and his perfect work, which leads into
what we just saw in Romans 3:21-31.
But how perfect does one have to get?
Trying your best like most Adventist
apologists and SDA theologians try and
put forth.
We've looked at this, I don't know how
many times.
Now, while our great high priest is
making the atonement for us, again,
investigative judgment, we should seek
to become perfect in Christ. Oh, okay.
How perfect is that?
Not even by a thought could our savior
be brought to yield to the power of
temptation. Satan finds in human hearts
some point where he can gain a foothold,
some sinful desire is cherished, by
means of which his temptations assert
their power. But Christ declared of
himself, "The prince of this world
cometh and hath nothing in me." John
14:30. Satan could find nothing in the
son of God that would enable him to gain
the victory. He had kept his father's
commandments, and there was no sin in
him that Satan could use to his
advantage.
This is the condition in which those
must be found who shall stand in the
time of trouble. Close quote.
So what's being perfect in Christ?
Trying your best. No. Identical
condition to Jesus. The character that
you must develop must be on par with God
in the flesh. That's how perfect you
must be. This is why it's silly to claim
that the last generation theology camp
is extreme and they're taking things too
far. No, they're consistent with the
system as a whole. This was the
consistent theme of Ellen White, not
trying your best.
Notice their their model of
sanctification here.
This visually depicts what I was just
laying out. Before the close of
probation,
you have to get to a condition in which
Jesus is no longer imparting his
righteousness to you because you've
arrived at a condition in which the law
is fulfilled in you.
The time of trouble occurs when
probation closes in their system. So
when Ellen says one must be found in the
same condition Jesus was in to be able
to stand in the time of trouble. This is
completely consistent with the rest of
the model.
And why I say this is consistent SDA
systematic theology. Labeling people in
their movement as hyperconservative or
whatever label people like Dr. Lake and
other modernists want to use is really
just mudslinging
because it's those hyperconservatives
that actually understand this thing
systematically and how all of this stuff
is connected and necessary.
It's not last generation folks that are
taking things out of context, Dr. Lake.
And I think deep down you realize how
ridiculous what they're saying is and
you still struggle with sin like every
other human being. But this creates a
cognitive dissonance with SDA theology
proper. So you seek to remedy that by
saying things, you know, things have
changed that that that was only true at
a point in the past, etc. But I digress.
In part two, we looked at how Ellen
White said, "If someone isn't keeping
the law, it's not that they can't, but
that they won't."
And the root cause of all of this is the
great controversy theme which says Jesus
came to silence accusations from Satan
in a pre-earth controversy that bled
into the earth where Satan was accusing
God's law of not being fair and that it
wasn't possible to be kept. No. Uh not
that it wasn't possible to try your
best.
Man was then created as a way of God
seeking to vindicate himself from these
accusations. So he created the earth and
mankind on a probationary test.
When they fell, Satan rejoiced. But God
the Father held a council meeting to
figure out a plan. And Jesus proposed
that he would incarnate, silence these
accusations, give man a second
probation, and demonstrate that a fallen
person can keep the law.
So, Dr. Lake, I know what you guys mean
by righteousness by faith. It's not the
saving grace of Adventist theology
like you did in the previous section.
you seem to be alluding to legalism that
1888 expelled that charge and made it
irrelevant regarding Adventism because
it established Adventism as being
christoacentric
which again is just more Christianes
that doesn't tell us anything. And I
plainly said in part two I rarely ever
use the term legalism for this exact
reason. It's a loaded term. Just because
you guys claim to be Christc centered
doesn't negate the fact that well one
you have a false Jesus but it doesn't
also negate the fact that you don't
actually think Jesus saves people. He
only makes something a possibility. He
can't be a savior without you being a
co-orker alongside him co-aboring with
Jesus who is basically your divine
cheerleader cheering you on doing what
he can but ultimately it's on you.
It doesn't negate the fact that you guys
teach the righteous righteousness of God
is obedience to the law of God.
Something Jesus will empower you to do
when no scripture is clear. The
righteousness of God was manifested
apart from the law because uh it comes
strictly on faith, not faith plus
obedience. You guys don't understand the
law gospel distinction. And I could go
on and on and on. So, I really hope that
in your books that you're writing about
me or whoever, whatever your guys's game
plan is, that you actually go beyond
these vagaries and standard SDA
platitudes and deal with the actual
objection. You guys have a worksbased
model of salvation. Period.
Works are misplaced and made to be
something they are not, which diminishes
the person and work of Christ. He can't
save without you being involved somehow.
Not even taking into account that you
guys also include Satan in redemption as
the scapegoat.
But Jesus's perfect person and work
isn't enough to save because his work
only opened a door making something
possible and he's trying his best now.
But his work isn't able to save in and
of itself.
Of course, you all are going to object
to this works charge, but name me one
workspace group that admits they're
workspaced. It doesn't change the facts,
though.
When looked at comprehensively, which
you seem to imply I haven't in the last
part, it's very clear what your guys'
model looks like. And it's Jesus plus
that saves you. It isn't Christ alone.
That's a false gospel put forth by your
prophetus. That's not Calvinism or
Antonyomianism or advocating for
lawlessness or any of the other standard
claims that we hear in response to this.
Back to 1888. Um, it was revived again
in 1988. the centennial of those
meetings and that's where George Knight
and others wrote prolifically about this
meeting bringing back what it
contributed to the church then and its
continuing contribution to us now
righteousness by faith the gospel of
salvation in Christ bringing
justification sanctification to to the
level of importance in Christian living
and Christian assurance so that's all
documented just to go back to to the
book I I bring out uh some observations
and uh I point out and this is what was
raised I believe in one of the streams
on answering Adventism in a in a
negative way. Uh but I point out that
Canrite when he he left Canr embraced
the old legalistic Adventism. Adventism
had spar second generation Adventism in
the 70s and early 1880s had spiralled
down into legalism literally legalism.
It was most unfortunate and that was the
situation that they were were
experiencing and Canrite was actually
had been a part of that himself in some
of his own arguments that I point out in
in my book.
But that left him cold. That left him
cold and and when he left Adventism,
that's what he attacked is that old
legalistic Adventism that can be
documented in his book and in
Adventism's experience and writings.
That's what he was attacking. But when
1888 happened, Canrite had left right
before the revival of 1888 and and the
the years afterward in 1887. And then
you read his later books, he never
mentioned that. He never turned back to
that. Presented Adventism and Ellen
White as hopelessly lost in legalism.
But he was arguing with that old
Adventism. True, legalism did continue
after that. But ever since 1888,
Adventism has been more focused on
Christ and the culmination of that is
the gospel as I shared earlier. But we
it's important to point out that Ellen
White herself and I have documented this
in my book in other places that she
understood the gospel way before 1888.
But as a result of 1888, she became more
outspoken, more pronounced
in emphasizing righteousness in Christ.
So we're not really hearing much in
defense of fundamental belief number 18.
This is more akin to their fundamental
belief number 11, which is called
growing in Christ. But he said 1888 led
to an understanding of the importance of
both justification and sanctification.
Here we go again.
We heard the same sort of thing in part
two and it's a common narrative that
SDAs often say to me because the
underlying narrative within Adventism is
that Christians are against
sanctification outright. They hold to
that that wrong uh instantaneous
sanctification
where nothing really changes in a
person.
We've heard this from Ted Wilson, Jud
Lake, Randy Ske, Walter Ve, and numerous
other SDA figureheads. And they're all
getting this from Ellen White, which is
why I guess it's fitting that Dr. Lake
is talking about this in the context of
the fundamental belief about her. Dr.
Lake, the objection from this platform
has not been that sanctification isn't a
part of salvation.
The Ordo Saludus,
it's never been that sanctification
isn't important.
It's that you guys don't distinguish
between justification and
sanctification. Hence why I very
regularly point out that your guys'
sotiology is medieval.
It is closer to the Roman Catholic
understanding which is supposed to be
your guys's arch nemesis.
You guys have a two-tiered system of
justification where you're initially
justified by grace through faith and
placed on the path of salvation. Your
justification before God is then
maintained by your obedience, which is
what sanctification is in your model.
Notice.
Whoops.
Ellen White, Bible sanctification is a
conformity to the will of God attained
by rendering obedience to his law
through faith in his son. Close quote.
Very forthright and simple. Just like I
showed earlier, just like I said
earlier, sanctification in your model is
attained by obedience to the law
empowered by faith. This is why your
obedience in the system plays a role in
your righteous standing before God
because you have to have Jesus's merits
gradually imparted to you. Getting to a
place of perfect lawkeeping where the
law is now fulfilled in you and Satan is
silenced. That's what sanctification is
about in this model. It is tied to
justification in that if you don't
attain to total perfection, you won't be
escatologically justified as we've
looked at before and will again in a
moment. But understand something. Ellen
White in this same chapter of Spirit of
Prophecy Volume 4 erently assumes that
if you don't agree with her false view,
you don't believe in real
sanctification.
She says this like I said in response to
the belief in an immediate complete
sanctification
a and parties who held to a view such
that there's no real change in a
person's life. So we get the false
dilemma fallacy. You either agree with
the SDA view or you hold to this other
view over here. No, this is not true.
SDAs are not the only ones that believe
in a progressive model of
sanctification. To prove this, let's
look at one example, the Westminster
Confession of Faith. But we could look
at the Augsburg. We could look at um the
1689 London Baptist, etc. Notice chapter
13 on sanctification.
They who are once effectually called and
regenerated, having a new heart and a
new spirit created in them are further
sanctified
really and personally
through the virtue of Christ's death and
resurrection by his word and spirit
dwelling in them. The dominion of the
whole body of sin is destroyed, and the
several lusts thereof are more and more
weakened and mortified, and they more
and more quickened and strengthened in
all saving graces to the practice of
true holiness, without which no man
shall see the Lord.
This sanctification
is throughout in the whole man yet
imperfect in this life. There abiding
still some remnants of corruption in
every part whence ariseth a continual
and irreconcilable war. The flesh
lusting against the spirit and the
spirit against the flesh. in which war,
although the remaining corruption for a
time may much prevail, yet through the
continual supply of strength from the
sanctifying spirit of Christ, the
regenerate part doth overcome, and so
the saints grow in grace, perfecting
holiness in the fear of God. Close
quote. What is instantaneous is a
person's righteous standing before God.
They have peace. The enmity is removed
because they're in union with Christ.
Their identity is now Jesus's identity
in terms of their standing before God.
Sanctification then takes place through
their entire life but is imperfect in
this life because man needs glorified
still to truly be entirely free. That
hasn't happened yet. The SDA system
tries to short circuit this. It's like
there should be Adventists that received
glorification today. They arrived at a
sinlessly perfect state today. They no
longer fall short of the glory of God.
But the application of glorification
happens when the body is resurrected.
Until then, the war with sin wages on.
So, Dr. Lake, Christopher, you guys, if
you guys engage on this subject, don't
regurgitate Ellen White's claims because
that's not the issue being presented.
Instantaneous versus progressive
sanctification.
It's that you guys teach progressive
sanctification is what will eventually
lead to an escatological justification.
And that is ultimately what will
determine if you have peace with God.
Which creates a two-tiered system where
Jesus is good enough initially to get
you in the door, but now it's dependent
upon you getting to a totally sinless
condition to then be rewarded with
eternal life. Yes, that's what Ellen
White said, rewarded.
When no, that's not what the purpose of
sanctification is.
The SDA model has people looking to
themselves and if they're holy enough to
be in favor with God. But notice what
Peter van, former professor from the
Seventh Adventist Theological Seminary,
says. We've looked at this before. Is
this a primary source, Dr. Lake? Is this
some fringe crackpot SDA in their
Ascension robe off in the corner
somewhere?
This is from his paper titled
Justification by Faith in Adventist
Understanding.
If our justification is through grace
alone, by faith alone, does the
obedience of faith have anything to do
with our salvation? Or to phrase the
question differently,
do our thoughts, words, and actions play
a role in determining our eternal
destiny? These are crucial questions
which are closely related to the issue
of the final judgment. Scripture has
much to say about that judgment, not
least in the teachings of our Lord as
recorded in the Gospels. said Jesus, I
tell you that men will have to give
account on the day of judgment for every
careless word they have spoken.
For by your words you will be acquitted.
The RSV and New King James say
justified. And by your words you'll be
condemned. Matthew 12:36-37.
Here our Lord talks about justification
and condemnation. The judicial
declaration of innocence and guilt in
the context of the la in the day of
judgment. Obviously, there's an
esqueological aspect of justification.
Adventists believe on the basis of
scripture that the day of judgment is a
very comprehensive concept and much
Adventist literature has been published
on the subject.
So, notice like I've said repeatedly,
the role of obedience in the system is
it maintains your chance of salvation.
It isn't Christ alone and his perfect
person and work. It is the Adventist
Jesus's work plus you. This is the same
paper where he starts by the way saying
that Adventists are heirs of the
Reformation.
No, you have zero business saying this
when you just what you just posited is
the exact opposite of what the
Protestant reformers were arguing. I
mean,
this was a key central issue to the
Reformation.
Not whether or not sanctification
happens at all, but that it's distinct
from justification.
What's called the ordo saludus, the
ordo, the the order of salvation. It
entails calling, predestining, electing,
justifying, sanctifying, and glorifying.
So to say that those that disagree with
the SDA view are saying sanctification
is not a part of salvation is incorrect.
We disagree with the SDA churches trying
a a tying together of sanctification and
justification such that your obedience
to the law maintains your justification.
Which means your salvation isn't
dependent upon Jesus. It's dependent
upon you. Jesus opened a door like Ellen
said earlier making it possible. But you
as a co- lababorer with him have to work
alongside him. They'll use all sorts of
phrases like Dennis Prebby likes to say,
"Well, you have to meet the conditions
of salvation. It's not work. You just
have to meet the conditions of
salvation."
Dennis Previous sounds like an
auctioneer
regarding Matthew 12:36 and 7. Notice
what John Calvin says in his Matthew
commentary. Since Mr. Vanmlin wants to
tell us that we're heirs of the
Reformation at the beginning of this
paper,
his wording is going to uh piss some
people off. I'm just giving you a heads
up now. Even citing from Calvin period
is going to set some people off, but so
be it.
What he put forth here, he claims is in
line with what the reformers believed.
Notice
on the phrase, "By thy words, thou shalt
be justified." The phrase that was in
question in Peter Vanellan's paper. This
is what Calvin writes. This was a common
proverb which he applies to the present
subject. For I have no doubt that this
was a saying which the people had
frequently in their mouths that every
man is condemned or acquitted by his own
acknowledgement.
But Christ turns it to a a meaning
somewhat different. That a wicked uh
that a wicked speech being the
indication of concealed malice is enough
to condemn a man. The attempt which the
papist make to torture this passage so
as to set aside the righteousness of
faith is childish. A man is justified by
his words, not because his speech is the
ground of his justification.
For we obtain by faith the favor of God,
so that he reckons to us uh reckons us
to be righteous persons, but because
pure speech absolves us in such a manner
that we are not condemned as wicked
persons by our tongue.
It is not absurd to infer from this that
men deserve a single drop of
righteousness in the sight of God.
On the contrary, this passage upholds
our doctrine. For although Christ does
not hear treat on the grounds of our
justification or treat of the ground of
our justification, yet the contrast
between the two words points out the
meaning of the word justify. The papists
reckon it absurd in us to say that a man
is justified by faith because they
explain the word justified to mean that
he becomes and is actually righteous.
While we understand it to mean that he
is accounted righteous and is acquitted
before the tribunal of God as is evident
from numerous passages of scripture.
And it is not the same thing. And is not
the same thing confirmed by Christ when
he draws a contrast between justified
and condemned.
Close quote.
Ah the exact thing that Peter van put
forth is the exact thing the reformers
were disagreeing with.
Now Rome often often refers to the
Protestant view as a legal fiction. But
that discussion aside, this is exactly
what Vanbean is saying that a person is
ontologically made a righteous being by
the gradual imparted righteous merits of
Jesus
because that's what the SDA churches uh
SDA church teaches. They'll tell you
they affirm you're both legally declared
righteous and then ontologically made
righteous also both justification and
sanctification just like Lake put forth.
He's not getting into any of this.
And then if you disagree with this,
they'll say you're against
sanctification or something to that
effect when no, we're against your
medieval understanding of
sanctification, wherein you chain it to
justification such that your doings
contribute being righteous before God.
All classical Protestant confessions
contain entire chapters on
sanctification.
None of them say this instantaneous
thing that Ellen White was arguing
against.
When I object to this, I'm typically
using more simple language like they
misplace obedience or they add to the
work of Christ. And this is what I'm
referring to.
Now, notice we're we're wrapping up
here, folks. Thank you for bearing with
me. I know it's been a lot. I I gave a
forewarning at the beginning, but this
is important. Notice what SDA scholar
Roy Gain says in Ministry magazine where
he actually tries arguing that John
Calvin in his Institutes of the
Christian Religion book three, he claims
that John Calvin was affirming what the
SDA church does on justification and
sanctification essentially being the
same. Sanctification being a part of
justification.
Quote, Luther and Calvin saw
justification as involving two
inseparable aspects.
The legal or forensic aspect is God's
forgiveness of the believer's sins and
his crediting Christ's righteousness to
their account. And two, the experiential
aspect is Christ's gift of his
righteousness to believers by the Holy
Spirit.
Now, I'm going to pause here. Remember
all these terms for Adventist theology
are defined by the great controversy
theme which neither Luther nor Calvin
had. But no, this is false. Luther and
Calvin did not believe justification
involved sanctification. The two are
distinct. Sanctification will absolutely
come. But it isn't an inseparable aspect
of justification. Like Roy Gain says,
this is the exact thing the Protestant
reformers were seeking to reform on this
subject. This was a central dividing
line of the Reformation, folks. To try
and put this forth, Roy Gain in his
paper appeals to the Lutheran Finish
School, which for now we're we're kind
of getting into like nerdy theological
stuff that most people aren't going to
know, but if you look at his footnotes,
he appeals to the Lutheran Finnish
School, which is notoriously known for
their rewriting of Lutheran history, to
try and argue a similar thing that early
Martin Luther affirmed this sort of
two-tier justification system. Yeah,
Luther reformed over the course of his
life. They try to appeal to these early
early statements when Yeah.
Some scholars have denied that Luther's
definition of justification includes the
gift of Christ to the heart by the
transforming presence of the Holy
Spirit. But reputable Lutheran scholars
have recognized the balance in his
thought between justification as God's
legal declaration and his gift of Christ
to the heart. Right? Lutheran scholars
from the Finnish school whom like I said
he footnotes and are notoriously known
for trying to twist Lutheran history.
But speaking of John Calvin and the
second point from earlier
that Calvin believed justification and
sanctification were tied that
justification has a second aspect which
involves sanctification.
quote on the second point that
justification involves the bestowal of
Christ upon our hearts by the presence
of the holy spirit Calvin wrote so now
he's going to cite from institutes of
the Christian religion book three in
this way is is this uh in this meaning I
deny not that Christ as he is God and
man justifies us that his work is common
also to the father and the holy spirit
in fine that the righteousness of which
God makes us partakers is the eternal
righteousness of the eternal God
provided effect is given to the clear
and valid reasons to which I have
adverted us one with himself and
therefore we glory in having a
fellowship of righteousness with him.
Calvin seems to have given greater
emphasis to the legal or forensic aspect
of justification than did Luther. Now
he's going to cite Wilheim Nissel's book
the theology of Calvin.
Calvin speaks of the believer being
grafted into Christ. That's union with
Christ whenever I use that term. So that
the concept of incorporation becomes
central to his understanding of
justification.
The austicia the the righteousness of
Christ on the basis of which man is
justified is treated as if it were man's
within the context of the intimate
personal relationship of Christ and the
believer. Close quote.
Wow. My whistling just
you get my point. Wow.
So Roy Gain thinks that what Calvin says
in his institutes and what Wilheim
Nissel is saying supports the Adventist
understanding of justification and
sanctification.
That the that's the point of this
article that the SDA view is supposed to
be supported by Calvin and Luther.
For starters, when they use the term
righteousness of Christ, they
fundamentally mean something different
than the SDA church. Radically
different. The SDA church means an
imparted similar to an infused
substantive righteousness that makes you
the individual righteous. Now, they're
going to disagree from say the the Roman
view of infusion where there is a dual
merits. They're going to try to say,
"No, it's only Jesus's merits."
But that's not at all what Calvin was
saying and was actually arguing against
that in the exact chapter that Roy Gain
is citing from as we will see
momentarily.
But the core issue here is union with
Christ.
Adventists do not believe what the
reform do or the Lutheran regarding
union with Christ.
We can get into arguing the temporal
order of things, but once a person comes
to Christ uh by faith, they are
justified and united to Christ,
transferred from the kingdom of darkness
to the kingdom of light. Justification
is now over at that point.
The next step is sanctification
where by virtue of being united to Jesus
Christ, a person will then be shaped and
molded by the Holy Spirit to be more
like Christ.
This comes from the indwelling of the
Holy Spirit and no longer being
spiritually dead, something the SDA
church does not believe.
This also gets into the importance and
centrality of Eucharist
and how we are fed on Christ.
We feed on Christ and his benefits in
the taking of the Eucharist which is an
actual means of grace that sanctifies us
and grows us.
But this is not an infusion of
righteousness that takes place that
increases justification
or leads to an esqueological
justification. Roy Gain apparently
didn't understand what Calvin meant by
union with Christ and in grafting. And
then he reads into that things he wasn't
saying
because notice
the chapter that he cited from to
support his claim. Chapter 11 of book
three in Calvin's Institutes.
This is the opening paragraph of the
chapter. Roy Gain didn't cite from the
beginning of the chapter. He jumps down
into the middle of the text. So, Dr.
Lake, pay very close attention here.
Your colleague did what you just accused
the critics of Adventism of doing
earlier. Pay very close attention, sir.
I know this is late. I know this is
scholastic type stuff, but we're going
to bury this lie because I'm sick of
hearing them say this
opening paragraph where Calvin is
setting the stage for the entire focus
of the chapter. Pay very close
attention.
Quote, I believe I've already explained
above with sufficient care how for men
cursed under the law there remains in
faith one sole means of recovering
salvation.
I believe I've also explained what faith
itself is and those benefits of God
which it confers upon man and the fruits
it brings forth in him. Let us sum these
up. So in the previous chapters he goes
through all sorts of of biblical texts.
He does all sorts of exoggetical work.
But now he's going to sum these up for
us.
And I'm not saying this whether you
agree with Calvin or not. The point is
Roy Gain didn't know what he's talking
about.
Let us sum these up. Christ was given to
us by God's generosity to be grasped and
possessed by us in faith. By partaking
of him, we principally receive a double
grace. Namely, that being reconciled to
God through Christ's blamelessness,
we may have in heaven instead of a judge
a gracious father.
And secondly, that sanctified by
Christ's spirit, we may cultivate
blamelessness and purity of life of
regeneration. Indeed, the second of
these gifts, I have said what seemed
sufficient.
The theme of justification was therefore
more lightly touched upon because it was
more to the point to understand first
how little devoid of good works is the
faith through which alone
alone
we obtain free righteousness by the
mercy of God. And what is the nature of
the good works of the saints?
With which part of this question is
concerned? Therefore, we must now
discuss these matters thoroughly and we
must so discuss them as to bear in mind
that this is the main hinge
main hinge
on which religion turns so that we
devote uh the greater attention and care
to it. For unless you first of all grasp
what your relationship to God is and the
nature of his judgment concerning you,
you have neither a foundation on which
to establish your salvation,
nor one on which to build piety toward
God.
Wow.
Notice that John Calvin says, "By
partaking of Christ, union with Christ,
one receives a double grace. The first
being complete reconciliation
and that is strictly on account of the
perfection of Jesus Christ who is
blameless
which turns our God from a judge to a
father.
Secondly, there is a grace involved in
sanctification which does transform our
lives. But this isn't a retention work
that maintains being reconciled.
It happens because of that first grace.
And this is central to the whole
discussion.
What the SDAs are putting forth is that
you are declared righteous and then
retain that righteous reconciliation
through sanctification.
Roy Gain trying to say Luther and Calvin
support this. No, I'm sorry gents. This
is not true. And for Calvin, this was
the hinge upon which religion turns.
Unless a person first grasps their
relationship to God, the nature of
judgment concerning the sinner after
coming to Christ, you have no foundation
to establish your salvation as well as
to build piety toward God upon. Meaning,
you have no basis to grow in holiness.
You're going to misplace that.
His entire point is is that if you mix
these two things, being reconciled to
God on the basis of Jesus Christ alone
and being made more holy as a result of
this, you have no sure foundation for
your salvation because it's not holy on
Christ alone. It's Christ plus something
else that isn't Christ. So, it's
imperfect and fallible.
And that's exactly correct. Not because
John Calvin said it, but because both
biblically and logically it's
consistent. But now notice what else
Calvin says in this chapter before uh
getting to to the quotes for that Roy
Gain used. This will be the last one and
we'll move on. But this is important.
These scholars will accuse people like
myself of not being comprehensively
read. Yet their own colleagues are doing
this exact same thing. Give me a break.
quote, "We explain justification simply
as the acceptance with which God
receives us into his favor as righteous
men."
And we say that it consists in the
remission of sins and the imputation of
Christ's righteousness.
Calvin believed that justification and
sanctification were
Yeah. Yeah.
Not past sins either, all sins. No
mention of sanctification here, Mr.
Gain. Calvin goes on to to discuss that
in a separate section. He says he
believed justification is simply the
acceptance with God that one receives
into his favor, being seen as righteous.
It consists of the remission of sins and
the imputation of Christ's righteousness
in full. You guys teach one enters into
the favor of God by keeping the ten
commandments.
We've looked at that. numerous times,
literally part of the plan of salvation,
the cha title of the chapter in Ellen
White's conflict of the ages series,
plan of salvation,
which again evidences the dangers in
mixing justification and sanctification.
But after this, there's about four
paragraphs of Calvin's biblical
arguments for these statements. After
giving those, he then says this in
response to Andreas Oandonder, who was a
a German theologian of of Calvin's day.
But Oandonder has introduced some
strange monster of essential
righteousness by which although not
intending to abolish freely given
righteousness, he has still enveloped in
it in uh he has still enveloped it in
such a fog as to darken pious minds and
deprive them from a lively experience of
Christ's grace. Consequently, before I
pass on to other matters, it behooves me
to refute this wild dream.
First, this speculation arises out of
mere feeble curiosity. Indeed, he
accumulates many testimonies of
scripture by which to prove that Christ
is one with us and we in turn with him.
A fact that needs no proof.
But because he does not observe the bond
of this unity,
he deceives himself.
Now it is easy for us to resolve all the
all of his difficulties. For we hold
ourselves to be united with Christ by
the secret power of his spirit. That
gentleman had conceived something
bordering on manachanism
in his desire to transfuse the essence
of God into man.
From this arises another fiction of his,
that Adam was formed to the image of God
because Christ had already been destined
as the prototype of human nature before
the fall. But because I am striving
after brevity, I must concentrate on the
present matter.
He says that we are one with Christ. We
agree. This is where the Lutherans and
the the Calvinists, the Presbyterians
disagreed regarding union with Christ.
But we deny that Christ's essence is
mixed with our own.
Then we say that this principle is
wrongly applied to those deceptions of
his. That Christ is our righteousness
because he is God eternal, the source of
righteousness, the ve and the very
righteousness of God.
Remember that term from earlier that EJ
Wagner used? Yeah. Just like Paul says
in Romans 3, that's what he's saying
here. Jesus is the very righteousness of
God, not the ten commandments.
My readers will pardon me if I now only
touch upon what my teaching plan demands
that I defer to another place. Although
he may make the excuse that by the term
essential righteousness, he means
nothing else but to meet the opinion
that we are considered righteous for
Christ's sake. Yet he has clearly
expressed himself
as not content with that righteousness
which has been acquired for us by
Christ's obedience and sacrificial
death, but pretends that we are
substantially
righteous in God by the infusion both of
his essence and of his quality.
Close quote.
Ah
right. Calvin is arguing against the
exact thing in this chapter that Roy
gains sights from to try and support
their model.
I said earlier the difference between
Calvinists and and and Lutheran
regarding union with Christ. Now what
there there we could rabbit trail off
into all of that. The issue there that
Calvin was saying was the the difference
in the bond being broken. So this is
again what I was saying. Lutheran
believe that you can forfeit
being in union with Christ essentially.
I don't believe that official like I
would need to look at at Augsburg and
and ask some Lutheran but I don't think
that they agree though with O what
Oander is putting forth here which is
the main thing that Calvin is arguing
against.
So no Luther again Luther didn't agree
with Roy Gain either. But just in terms
of using Calvin, Calvin is arguing
against the idea that Christ's own
righteous essence is mixed with our own.
He's arguing against the subst the
substantial righteous idea of being
infused. SDAs typically use the term
imparted which then makes the individual
substantally righteous.
The SDA position is what Andreas
Oandonder was advocating for and
precisely what Calvin is arguing
against.
So Dr. Lake, post 1888 Adventism
regarding justification and
sanctification is not alleviated.
Roy Gain's article is from 2009.
This is what you guys teach. It is
legalistic to claim that faith plus
obedience to the law reconciles a
person.
He mentioned my discussion with Steve
Daly where I said post 1888 Adventism is
not um different from pre-188
or or yeah post1 1888 adventism isn't
different from pre-188. So saying can's
criticisms you know are in error
whatever. No I was not in error sir
canrite's criticisms on the subject
still stand and 1888 isn't an antidote
for that problem. Canright rightly
understood the proper role of both
justification and sanctification.
In fact, it's in his discussion of
sanctification that he denounces
antinomianism
and says that Adventists falsely label
anyone that disagrees with them as an
antonyomian, which isn't fair. This is
precisely what still happens today. I
hear it from Adventists constantly. It's
the assumption that there was this
radical change in 1888 that's the
problem. Canright didn't need to
reference that because fundamentally the
problem's still the same.
You guys teach a person maintains their
right standing with God based on their
obedience. Not the perfect passive and
active obedience of Christ where by
being united with Christ, a person is
seen as totally righteous because Jesus
is again Roy Gain did not understand
what Calvin meant by union with Christ.
And if you miss that, you'll
fundamentally miss what he was saying on
the any aspect of salvation for that
matter. be it justification or
sanctification. He said since 1888
Adventism has been more more Christc
centered again Dr. Like which Christ?
Who is Christ? The Adventist Jesus
who was also rightly criticized by
Kright.
Sir being more focused on Christ does
not change the great controversy
worldview which informs why the
Adventist Jesus incarnated to silence
Satan show the law can be kept and that
you can get to a totally sinless state
in which that will vindicate God's
character and you can side with Christ
in the great controversy and yada yada.
That's still the engine under the hood.
Even if you guys give the vehicle a new
paint job.
Yes, Dr. Lake, we saw Ellen White's
understanding of the gospel in the last
part. He mentioned Ellen White's
understanding of the gospel. And sadly,
she didn't understand the true gospel
either.
It's like between Wesian fanaticism and
the great controversy worldview, the
devil totally scrambled her mind to the
true gospel and she ended up being used
as a tool of Satan. to be perfectly
honest.
But he goes on in the rest of the video
to focus on on canite and legalism
within aism. But I've made my points and
my criticism criticisms are known.
This entire response from them folks was
a promo for books, an appeal to make
Adventists seem innocuous to the
unsuspecting listener and posture to
SDAs that answering Adventism has been
addressed.
Yet, we saw not a single point of
contention engaged. We saw some dancing
around some claims that I made with
Steve Daly,
meaning 1888 was the closest thing he
came to engaging.
But it was a comment that I made in
passing to Steve Dailyaly. It wasn't
even like a foundational criticism that
I've regularly brought up. We heard very
little about Ellen White during the
section which was supposed to be focused
on Ellen White. But all in all, Dr.
relate. Christopher, my mind has not
been changed
on any of my points of contention that
I've raised.
And it sounds like to actually hear your
guys's true engagement, I'm going to
have to buy a book, which whatever,
that's fine.
Possibly you guys are tasking the the
the guys up in Tacoma Park to help you
out. But let me be clear, you guys are
going to really need to study my
criticisms.
Dr. Lake, I'm glad that you recognize
not all former Adventists are the same.
We're not all coming from the same
theological foundations, even if we may
be united on the same fundamentals of
the Christian faith. We often arrive at
the same conclusions, but we do not use
the same route to get there. And the
route that you use to get there is just
as important as the conclusion.
More and more Adventists, sir, are
quietly watching and seeing what's being
said. They are getting redpilled on the
truth.
They're hearing actual cogent arguments
that are biblically rich and not
dependent on an extra-biblical worldview
that's rooted in a woman from the 19th
century.
Arguments that your guys' system was not
built understanding.
Cuz my arguments are not novel to me. I
stand on the shoulders of giants.
But I understand the theological
landscape better than the average
Christian. I'm not a master, but I'm
also not a novice.
And I know where your pioneers got their
arguments from. I know how they twisted
beliefs to fit with the great
controversy worldview. I sat quietly in
an office for 10 years as a student. I
didn't start answering Adventism
overnight. It wasn't it it wasn't
hastily.
It was very calculated.
So, I look forward to the day that you
guys meaningfully engage the very direct
criticisms, not use a lot of Christian
word salads to make it appear like you
did,
but you showcase you actually understand
the issues.
You're telling your students that I
misrepresent you guys.
You said it here.
Yet you didn't interact with a single
primary source out of thousands
potentially,
guaranteed hundreds,
thousands we've potentially cited on
this platform and demonstrate how I've
abused any of them.
None.
You should have a plethora of them to
pull from since it's just all out of
context. Oh, it's just all these
critics. They just they don't they just
don't know. Yeah, it's easy to say that
in your your theological ivory tower,
sir, in the air conditioned halls of SDA
academia. It's different out here in the
the the apologetic world where you
actually have to have your beliefs
tested and understand what people
actually believe.
The charge you're saying, I
the beauty of understanding the true
gospel, folks, is that I don't have to
have any of this pressure to convince
people, to change people's minds, etc.
because I know that God can freely save
people in and of himself. He's capable
and able to freely save those whom he
desires. We simply pray here to be used
in that and that God has and God has
answered that by bringing lots and lots
of Adventists out of darkness into the
light. There's no amount of SDA
scholastic bloation and books that can
change this because truth is on our
side, not the SDA churches. So, we're
going to keep shining the light and and
trusting God and watch the enemy, you
know, that is the SDA church be put
under the feet of Jesus Christ. And in
the process, we pray that you both will
come to a saving knowledge of the true
Christ and his gospel. Dr. Lake, next
time I'm down your way, I'll take you
out to lunch and we can talk about this
further. Thank you all for being here
and may Christ richly bless you in the
grace and peace won by Jesus Christ and
his vic uh vicarious death on the cross
for sinners. Marinatha. Amen.
[Music]